you
uh okay i'm going to uh
open the executive session on uh
for uh finance
and recess it until 10 30.
you
um
maureen could you still make the motion
okay sorry for the delay um
we just had a few things to iron out
so
um our first bill is hb
uh 1235
relative to compensation paid to a crime
victim
representative weiler
thank you madam chair i would like to
offer an amendment mike hoffman will
pass it out
along with
mickey
mickey lander do you know the number
in case anyone's interested i don't
think we have any bills that don't have
amendments so
we'll be uh
we'll be enjoying
actually we do we have one
i would like to move amendment 1170
and i'll speak to my amendment do i have
thank you
okay
okay the the 1235
contained portions
that uh
changed
h frm the frm
was dealt with in hb2
it's been dealt with for several years
there's a section of law 359 p
that puts out all the details of of the
frm settlement fund
we changed it a little bit
in
um
hb2 we put the money in in hb2 we also
repealed the repeal so there's no
further action that i think needs to be
done
on
frm and the way that bill
was amended and the second amendment was
confusing so this is going to take all
that out and just leave in the bill as
it was intended to raise the forty
thousand to fifty thousand
for the victims of of uh violence and
that's the way the bill should be
cleaned just dealing with that issue
so
i moved the amendment
yeah we we had a first in a second
already uh representative walt
as one of the original sponsors of the
bill
i would take issue with the fact of the
way the bill was originally intended i
would argue that
the section that's being removed here
takes the residual part of whatever
money is left on frm and moves it to the
victims assistance fund if there is
money left that actually was part of the
original intention of the bill
because the original sponsor in this was
none other than the late representative
cushing and representative cushing often
said to me that we should never have
done a separate fund for the frm victims
because they're already existed in law
the victims compensation fund and they
were eligible to apply to the victims
compensation fund but chose not to and
so
they had a an approach of recovery
available to them
so his thought was is that since we put
this money in the
uh
fund for the frm
and it really is a different form of a
victims compensation fund that any money
left over should go to the already
existing victims compensation fund that
does compensate other victims of crime
throughout the state
so i would suggest that the amendment
then guts the basic intention one of the
two basic intentions of the bill
and that is that it eliminates the
ability to take any residual money and
allow it to be used for other crime
victims
thank you
represent weiler
i don't think there will be any
residuals so we shouldn't make that
anticipation
i think there's likely to be
may i respond
say something
and i think if we find out in a year or
so that there is a residual that's the
time to
do something thank you
may i respond
did you raise your hand
thank you representative waltz you just
didn't see it um but i would suggest
what is the harm in doing it now why is
there a problem with acknowledging now
that if there's money left it can go to
compensate other victims of crime you
would put this off later you know
obviously representative cushing's not
going to be here later others of us may
not be here this seems like as good a
time as any to do this and therefore i
oppose this amendment i think the bill
as it came to us
you know we are not a policy committee
this is effectively changing the policy
because there was a policy here to put
the money in for other crime victims
it's not just a financial issue it's a
policy issue and here we are once again
trying to make policy here and i would
argue it should be as it arrived to us
as a policy bill because this will have
no effect on the current expenditures of
the state so i think this is just an
attempt to change policy and i oppose
this amendment
thank you
represent wyler i am attempting to
preserve what we did in hb2 that was the
committee action in this committee and
i'm attempting to preserve it rather
than have it meddled with thank you
are there any other comments
thank you madam chair
uh representative weiler yes
representative burris yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin
representative edwards yes
representative lynn
yeah
representative turcotte yes
representative nor
no
norgren
representative bucco
representative leishman
no
representative hatch no
representative rogers
is it working now yeah okay
i'm sorry
yes
representative heath was a yes okay
representative berger yeah
yes
matter of chair the vote is 13 to 8
for hb
1235 fn
uh
could i now have a
uh motion
to pass as amended yes madam chair i
move ought to pass as amended on house
bill 1235 and i'd like to speak to my
motion
second
seconded by
representative griffin
thank you madam chair uh division one
voted in favor of this bill with just
one a descending vote
uh the bill as amended coming from or
rather coming from the judiciary
committee increases the cap of the
victims assistance program which is
administered by the department of
justice
it increases it by ten thousand dollars
from forty thousand dollars to fifty
thousand dollars per claimant per
incident for reasonable expenses set
forth
in rsa chapter 21 hyphen capital m colon
8 hyphen little h
roman
5. such expenses that are typically used
for this victims program include medical
funeral counseling rehabilitative
expenses as well as lost wages and costs
of participating in court
proceedings the ending
balance in the fund
for fiscal year 2021 having looked at
the annual report for the program which
was issued last fall is close to a
million dollars
so i believe it's the
intent of the division and hopefully
this committee
that the increase can be absorbed by
these available funds
and make mention of the fact that the
fund is funded by federal funds
restitution penalty grants and so on
no state funding there
so i would encourage my colleagues on
the committee to vote in favor of ought
to pass as amended on house bill 1235
are there any further comments represent
leishman
thanks madam chair just a clarification
with the amendment we just passed
wouldn't that not change that any
funding going to the victims fund
go ahead
represent
thank you um as we just amended it with
the wyler amendment it would now just
increase the cap i was simply giving
some background on the assistance
program
as a refresher for those who may need it
yes
indeterminable
i i think the key here is that the
victim
what is called victim witness fund
is um
that that amount of money comes out of
the federal government
and they provide it to uh
justice and justice disperses it uh
throughout the uh
the state to the counties thanks venom
chair
uh representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair um
it's it's my understanding i'm looking
for some clarification here the first
line of the amendment we pass says amend
the bill by replacing all after section
1 with the following
does is that meant to be interpreted
that section 1 of 1235 remains standing
or did it also get wiped out in the
replace all after section one how do we
interpret that sentence
no section one remains
section two is eliminated
okay
seeing no other
people wanting to comment will the clerk
please call the roll
thank you madam chair
uh representative weiler
you yes
represents the burrish yes
arizona petrie votes yes
representative tracy
emerick yes
hey we get it we get all of them
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative berner
representative lynn
yes
representative mooney
representative shercott
yes
representative organ
representative pucco yes
representative leishman
yes
president of hatch
representative walls yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger yeah
yes madam chair the vote is 21-0 on hb
1235 ought to pass as amended
that's it
we can't go and consent because it
contains dollars
question on that
as as it comes out of the committee it
it there's no change from what the house
has already passed on a policy
i mean i
i don't i think we need to just leave it
okay
uh
uh relative to payment but
relative to payment by the state of a
portion of retirement system
contributions
of a political subdivision may have a
motion thank you uh representative
griffin
do i have a second
um i i move itl just a moment
represent turcotte seconds the motion
madam chair i don't think i made the
motion
yes you did okay
that was true
no turcotte seconded it
and represented griffin made the motion
this bill would have the state pay
7.5 percent of the retirement system
contributions
of its political subdivisions
for group one and group two employees
the bill came out of its policy
committee executive departments and
administrations
with an itl recommendation
and the full house
initially
voted itl
on the bill
it was later reconsidered at the end of
the day
after many members had left
and it passed by the slimmest of margins
the finance committee opposes the bill
on multiple grounds
the bill would change the state's policy
and the policy committee had rejected
that change
the cost of the bill is a function of
the number of employees
of the state's political subdivisions
and the state has no control
over that number
the bill's current estimated cost
is roughly 28 million
in both fiscal year
and fiscal year
2025.
that is budget money that the state may
not have at that time
but most importantly
with an effective date of july 31
passage of the bill would encumber a
future legislator's budget
which is never good policy
thank you madam chair
are there any further comments i'll rep
some leashman
thanks madam chair and
certainly i think perhaps the members
that did vote on this later saw the
error of their ways and that's why the
bill passed on the floor but
um
the state
as i think all of us know started in
by providing 40 percent
of the contribution rate to
municipalities that helped offset that
contribution
then in
77 we reduced it down to 35 percent
2009 we reduced it down to 30 percent
with the hope at that time because i was
here that we would at least bring it
back when the state's coffers were a
little healthier than they were in 2009
however in
the legislature reduced it entirely i
think the 7.5 percent is reasonable the
state as as we all know is at least the
coffers are full this time around and at
the very least i think we can make a
small contribution to help offset
municipal contributions to the
retirement system thanks
thank you are there further comments
when we reduced it to zero
we increased the contributions by the
members
so that it
took away most of the cost of
what we had what we would have paid from
the state
the important thing is here when we sit
down to make a budget we interview all
these departments and we put them under
strict
control to spend no more than what we
give them
that's impossible
if we're going to contribute to the
retirement systems of municipal and
county employees we have no control over
that piece
they could keep hiring people and hiring
people they could keep giving
increases in pay and each of those
actions would make this more expensive
to the state so going forward
looking at 27 months when we finish our
budget there's no prediction what this
could amount to it's a dangerous way
to do any kind of funding so that's why
we need to be able to have something
controllable when we decide we're going
to give the towns 100 million that's a
set amount when we decide we're going to
give the towns an increased portion of
meals and rooms that's a set amount it
won't go out unless we get it in so
there's no way that would unbalance the
budget but this
if we get into the habit of paying for
retirement systems for
for non-state employees
then
we could easily unbalance the budget so
i think we shouldn't do that we
shouldn't do any action that's going to
lead down that road thank you
uh thank you representative waltz
thank you madam chairman i would suggest
that the argument that the towns are
going to just hire and hire and then
have an imposition on the state is
nothing but a straw man the towns have
no motivation to hire because they have
to pay the salaries of those and those
town budgets are tight one only has to
attend a regular be a regular attendee
of town meeting to know how hard it is
to get a new employee into a town budget
so i think that argument is nothing but
a straw man the real argument here is
property taxes
the state when the state dropped this in
2009 there was a huge spike in property
taxes for the counts and to suggest that
it was made up for by the additional
employee compensator contributions is
just wrong
there was a huge increase in local
property taxes
we have citizens throughout the state
who are suffering who are having to sell
their homes who are dealing with all
kinds of things because we have crammed
so much down on the towns that was once
paid for by the state we owe it to our
local communities to start returning
some of the contribution that we should
be paying for the retirement systems
that we once paid and that we suddenly
pulled the rug out from under them
i think that we should be passing this
and that we should be sending money to
the towns and give us some property tax
relief to our citizens throughout the
state
uh
representative heath i just want to say
i concur completely with representative
walsh's testimony thank you
uh
representative edwards uh yes ma'am i'm
i'm just curious about the rules of
decorum um the previous member uh
attacked the argument calling it a straw
man which uh i don't know gets pretty
close to impugning motives i'm i'm just
what is your determination on that ma'am
uh it was fine thank you
seeing none will the clerk call the role
this is itl
thank you madam chair the
the motion is itl on hb 1417
representative weiler
yes
representative petry votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner
yes
representative lin
representative norgren
no
representative bucco no
arizona leashman no
roger rogers no
rosanna walsh
no
representative heath no
representative murray
yes madam chair the vote is 11 to 10 in
favor
okay the vote being 11 to 10 uh we will
recommend itl
uh folks please make sure that your
microphone is
close to you
because as you know we are
live streaming this
and
the folks out there that might be
listening to it
need to um
need to make sure that that they can
are we short of mike over there
moving on to
hb
1496 requiring political subdivisions to
make voter checklists available in
spreadsheet form
to any residence
do i have a motion for otp
yes madam chair i make a motion of otp
ought to pass on house bill 1496.
and do i have a second by uh
are there any comments
if i could madam chair please just a
brief background this bill uh came from
election law uh it also went through a
division vote on the floor of the house
it came out of division one here in
finance seven to zero
uh essentially what the bill will do is
allow the voter checklist to be
available in a spreadsheet form
at the request of a resident of a town
or city
once a month maximum
the fee structure that's currently in
statute for voter checklists remains in
place
so there is no financial
burden
with regards to the passage of this bill
today now i'll have you know election
law amended the bill
and with that came an amended fiscal
note that was
i just received myself yesterday
so i want to be sure
that you're aware that the original bill
as drafted
reflects a decrease of a hundred
thousand dollars to the budget that is
incorrect
because the bill has been amended from
election law
and you'll notice uh if
we have the new fiscal note
it says that there is no impact on the
state
funds
so i want to make that very clear
the reason likely for that is because
originally when the bill was drafted
it was
undetermined whether or not the
checklist in a spreadsheet form would be
a fee would be for a fee
and as it turns out in the amended
version and i've confirmed this with
several sources yes the spreadsheet does
have the same fee structure that's in
the law now
so with that i would ask you all to
support my motion of ought to pass thank
you madam chair
are there further comments questions
representing edwards
if um
if this came from the policy committee
otp and because of the amendment there
is no fiscal impact shouldn't we just
simply vote otp and put this on consent
well we'll get to that we have to vote
first
i just wanted to know where we were
going
okay are there any further comments
okay well the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh you're voting
on house bill 1496 fn ought to pass
representative weiler yes
president the burris yes
president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner yes
representative lynn
yes
representative mooney
representative shercott yes
president walner
yes
president orgrim
virginia bucco yes representative
leishman
yeah
president of hatch yes
president of rogers
representative walsh
yes
version of heath
and representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
veterans here the vote is 21-0 on house
bill 1496 fn okay
1496 fn passes on a vote of 21
to 0.
uh does anyone have any objection to
this
seeing none we'll put it on the consent
calendar
we now turn to hb 1535
relative to cost of living adjustments
for
retirees in the state retirement system
uh
represent hatch
yes thank you thank you madam just just
a moment i'm sorry yeah representative
hatch is proposing
amendment
which was approved by the division
so um
could i have a motion
or
otp a
no i got to do the amendment first yes
excuse me
okay
representative patch
thank you madam chair to speak to your
amendment uh
2022-1151
thank you madam chair sorry for jumping
the gun that's quite all right
and for house bill 1535
and uh representative bleachman and i
are proposing
amendment number one one five one excuse
me just a second i'm sorry
representative hatch is moving
oh yes okay the amendment i move
amendment uh getting there 202 i get out
way back in the bus way back
i move amendment number 2022
1151 h okay and representative leachman
seconds
okay
now i'm sorry thank you madam chair and
i apologize and i'll speak to the
amendment
um
what this does essentially i'll just
speak to what it does is is it
gives a
patent of 500
to each member of the reminder
retirement system
um this
currently uh receives a benefit under
thirty thousand dollars per year
um
now it's added to the underlying bill
which
was to give
the retirees with more than five years
uh
service a one and a half percent cola
and have that going forward
um recognizing that
one we're not in a budget year
two the cost of that would be
72.2 million dollars
the likelihood of that going forward was
non-existent
and we understand that and recognize
that
not
not exceeding not
but we also understand there's a dire
need for some sort of
recognition and contribution to the
retirees
that haven't received any form of cola
since 2019 and that
was merely another 500
um
one-time payment to all retirees again
put this amendment forward primarily
recognizing that there is a need
we're currently in in a high inflation
economy and um
i i believe many of the people that are
depending on their retirement
to sustain their way of living are
having an
incredibly hard time
also we heard a lot of and that's that's
the obvious for a cola and that's the
obvious for
helping out the retirees on the
retirement system but one thing that
also has occurred since there was a
decrease in the retirement
and um
departments
and we heard a lot of testimony to this
fact are having
a tremendous amount of trouble
recruiting
that they currently have in the driver
of that
issue i believe is the retirement system
one of the motivation fact mode of
motivation factors for people to choose
a career with the state
is
they understand that their remuneration
during their service is not as much as
it could be otherwise
but they also were attracted by the fact
that there's a
a good retirement system available to
them and it would be available to them
in in and
when they're still at a at a reasonably
young age those that
and that was one of the primary factors
in recruitment and retainment of
personnel
since like i stated
there was a change in the retirement
system
people have flooded the doors leaving
the state service
we heard testimony currently for an
example in our prison system
the guards there serve a very important
function they're now dealing with a 60
percent shortfall of personnel
which which alone makes that a
undesirable and even a dangerous
circumstance
so
even though i would like to do more um
this amendment
does give some recognition to their need
but it's also we understand that this is
an issue that needs to be addressed and
hopefully sooner than later we can
put the appropriate funding behind the
retirement system thank you madam chair
and i urge you out to pass thank you are
there further comments representative
weiler
i agree that if someone was living on
this only this pension
that yes every little bit helps but in
the past
when we gave
uh a
a cost of living increase or or a
stipend and just a single one-time
stipend we looked at the whole income
there could be somebody
making under 30 000 in
in the state retirement but they could
also have a military pension and the
social security added to that so i think
in the past we've used total income
rather than just the income that was
coming from the retirement system and i
wonder why we didn't do it this time
represent waltz
thank you representative weiler it is my
understanding that group 2 employees are
not eligible for
social security and the fact that they
pay a windfall tax on their state
retirement benefits already because of
the nature of the benefits and the
nature of federal tax law
so i would suggest that
um for many of these people this is
their only source of income because they
are not eligible for social security
thank you that's irrelevant
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair um and this is
to representative hatch if i may i
i
i appreciate the fact that we have a
problem we'd like to fix which is the
um
decline in or the amount of attrition
that's taking place prior to retirement
i i just don't see the connection
between a one-time
500 payment and a long-term incentive to
maintain
uh employment
and and and it also makes me wonder
uh if we pay a one-time 500 dollar
payment aren't we really
signaling that they can expect more
one-time payments in the future i mean a
one-and-done doesn't seem like that
would hold up what what are your
thoughts on that sir
well thank you for the question uh just
a moment please sorry representative
hatch you may respond
thank you madam chair we'll get there
i know
um
i i understand your comment but um
a
the 500 one-time payment is in
recognition of the need and also we're
in hyperinflation and my thoughts to
that exactly my personal thoughts is
maybe maybe it would just help
some of those that are really really
struggling on their retirement from the
state
it might allow them to buy a tank full
of fuel
or whatever
it is just an immediate assistance to
the need that i'm sure many of them have
and
so the intent of this is not for
retainment when i was talking about that
i was just speaking to the retirement
system at all
as a whole
and we have
taken away the attractiveness
of the state retirement system to many
many people who at one time
considered having a career with the
state but no longer do and and it's
really a serious problem
and the one that was spoken to the most
and passionately was the issue at our
prison system um we're creating some
dangerous circumstances with the lack of
personnel so we have to do something
to address that and i do know this been
here long enough that there was a strong
recruitment program there was a very
good retainment
stat
mainly because of the retirement system
that was in place for those that are
serving us thank you
are there any
yes represent
burner yes i'm the prime sponsor of this
bill for a lot of the reasons that
representative hatch brought this up
for clarification we did the one-time
payment
a couple of years ago which was
unanimous in the house but we did that
with a fifty thousand dollar mark so
when i wrote when i submitted the bill i
put it at thirty thousand dollars to try
to address the average person
under the thirty thousand are averaging
around a nineteen thousand dollar
pension
and i was trying to get something like a
caller i know that's budget
but this isn't much as a budget buster
because the last one did have some
impact the last payment i know it had
some impact and that's why i went with
the uh thirty thousand dollar level
so we didn't get the group two in and
all that so
just for clarification thank you
thank you very much are there further
comments
seeing none will the clerk call the role
on the amendment
thank you madam chair this is house bill
1535 fn
the amendment is 1151 h
representative burris yes
representative petri volch yes
representative emrick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner
yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative yes
representative walner
yes
representative organ yes
representative buco yes president
leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
arizona walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umbrer
yes
madam chair the host bill 1535 fn
any affirmative thank you
uh the vote being 21-0 on amendment 1151
it passes
uh
president
thank you do i have a second
represent leashman
are there any further comments or
discussion on
otpa motion
seeing none
are you ready
yes i am okay
click call the roll
uh this is on uh hb 1535 fn ought to
pass as amended representative wilder
yes
representative burrish yes there's on
petrie of lgs representative emerick
no
representative earth yes
representative griffin
yes
representative edwards yes
representative burner
yes
representative lynn yes
rosanna mooney
no
representative no
representative organ yes
robertson buco yes
representative leishman yes
president of hatch
yes
original walsh yes
president heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes representative of the vote
uh you know madam chair the vote is 18
oh i'm sorry what'd i say you said
well i'm i wasn't i didn't mean that
uh on uh yeah otp fa on 1535 okay
otpa passes 18 to 3.
okay we now move to hb uh
and we have an amendment wait a minute
did you did you want that on uh no we
can't put it on consent yeah i'd love to
put it on consent
okay
i'd love to put all these on consent
but
okay uh this is amendment
to
could i have a motion to accept
amendment two zero two two one zero nine
five so representative griffin
do i have a second
second thank you representative emrick
who's the primary question
representative griffin i understand
this i am the amendment makes
four minor changes to the original bill
and
basically
it uh
it clarifies
the
the laws that are referenced
originally rsa
594 a6
was referenced below on line 19
and now the amendment brings it up to
line 12
and
there was some clarification of language
that just made the bill more clear
is there any further discussion on the
amendment
representative norgren
yeah and are these
is this amendment amenable to the
i'm sorry i couldn't hear
uh is the amendment okay with the
i i believe it is i haven't checked
personally
seeing none will the clerk call the role
on amendment 10
20 22
thank you madam chair uh
representative weiler yes
presenter burrish yes
president petri votes yes representative
emmerich
yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes president
murder yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
arizona sure caught
original walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
original walls yes
representative heath yes
president murray yes
representative umbrerger
yes
madame sharer hb 1540 has a vote
as amended by
h okay
21 to zero thank you
amendment
uh could i have a motion on 1540
as otpa so move madam champ thank you
representative griffin seconded by
will the clerk call the roll
think about it this is on otpa
okay this great otpa okay represent
wilder
yes
representative the burris yes original
petri votes yes representative emerick
yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
president turcotte
representative walner
yes
representative norgren
yes representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
of murray yes representative umberger
yes
uh yes
passes otp
a
thank you uh
hb 1540 fn
otpa
at 21 to zero
we now move i'm sure that could go on
consent
that can go
that can go on consent because there's
no cost
saying none
okay we will now move to hp 1550
fn
uh could i have an otp motion please
so moved
representative mooney
do i have a second
that was otp
[Music]
and america's isekah
thank you
representative mooney would you like to
speak to your motion i would thank you
madam chair
as means of some background this bill
came absolutely flying out of the edna
committee unanimously
into division one it came out of
division one here in this committee as a
five to two vote
essentially what this bill would do is
move the board for the certification of
assessors from
the dra
to
the
oplc office of professional licensing
spark that started this
was that currently the board for the
certification of a successors
under the dra
doesn't have disclosure
like they would under the oplc
for example licensing
discipline and the like
if this move were to be made
fees would be
involved
with regards to licensing of assessors
currently
with the board under the dra there are
no fees
it is fees that would fund this
board under the oplc
and with that i would
ask that the committee vote in favor of
ought to pass
are there any questions
uh representative leishman
thanks madam chair i won't be supporting
this motion
there are several things that caught my
eye during the discussion one the dra
did not
ask for this change and in my belief the
dre has done a fairly
good job overseeing assessors
one of their responsibilities one of
many this creates a fine structure
without an appeals process
it also creates a fee
and i know my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle have never been really
in favor of fees but
i just think the way things have gone
for years with the dra and their
oversight of assessors in the process
has been done well so i will not be
supporting the motion madam chair
thanks
thank you um
just based on a thank you madam chair
just based on a conversation i had uh
recently with regards to the fee
structure which is certainly true um the
balance here is transparency and
government
and that was the the motive behind
offering the bill in the first place
and uh it seems that that transparency
is uh
what outweighed
uh the fee structure uh in the entire
edna committee and the majority of our
division one thank you madam chair
thank you are there any for any further
comments madam
uh
representative walner
i just have a question of division one
certainly
uh did you hear from the assessors
themselves
the answer to your question is not as i
recall however
they did testify to edna
i watched that hearing
and it was the board
the chair it was the vice chairman of
the board of assessors who testified
and uh was in favor of the bill
in fact it was his testimony i found
quite critical in terms of the
background and the intent of the move
representative griffin
thank you madam chair
i believe this is a
solution looking for a problem
i think the board of excesses at the dra
has worked well
we know that the dra didn't have a
position on this
and
and i suspect that fees are going to go
up and maybe
maybe other costs and
i tend to vote no
thank you are there any other comments
versum hatch
thank you madam chair
i voted for this in division three
and and i have to admit i'm division one
excuse me i have to admit that i have
since
uh given a lot of thought and talked to
a few individuals concerning this and
i'm and i'm thinking i may change my
vote um that i had in the division
primarily um
i supported this because a i have a lot
of confidence in the oplc and i still
carry that um but
when i
asked a few questions of the assessors i
knew
and tried to weed out the necessity for
this
and and i got the blank stare
they're not not aware and and i i think
the statement that maybe this is a
solution looking for a problem um
i don't know of any cases that i've
heard up and that's what i asked a few
assessors where if there was an issue
with whatever they did
the person that had issue with it have
why they did what they did in other
words they they were open to any
questions and any documentation they had
is open to the public so um
and as far as a fee goes
the only stop check for this this that
has changed in this legislature uh in
the last few terms
now they would go to a
rules gel card
and
it was there where the fee would be
reviewed
um having chaired gel cart and have been
have having been a member of that for
many years um we really don't have the
time
or even the wherewithal
um
to do a complete
investigation of the fees the fee
structures um as we did in ways and
means though though we try and i'm not
saying gel car doesn't do its job but
there's not the time
or the staff
or the ability to pay the very close
scrutiny to fees
that has been done in ways and means so
um i apologize for this but i i need to
change my vote and i no longer support
this change without some further
thought and investigation thank you
madam chair
thank you and uh thank you for being on
gelcar
brutal
yeah i think
it's worse than appendicitis there's no
question in my mind or having a tooth
bolt
so um
thank you thank you for that madam chair
representatives yes
thank you madam chairman to answer
representative walder's question the
answer is no
being the clerk for division one
i wish that somebody from the board of
associates would have been present
because i had some questions during and
even after
you know our hearing so
i was a little bit disappointed that
nobody seemed to care or take interest
in the bill thank you
are there further comments or questions
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair i
i think i'm gonna vote no on this and
i'll accept that there is a problem that
we found and the found problem is
uh a perception that there's a lack of
transparency i just would like to see
that addressed rather than
moving the assessors over into an
environment in which a fee structure is
going to be added to them and given that
so many of these are employed by city
and state
these would become reimbursable expenses
the fees so i you know in this era of
trying to reduce pressure on property
taxes this would just be another burden
to push downhill so i think i'll be
voting now
are there further questions
represent mooney in a last attempt here
on house bill 1552 to
preserve the unanimous
uh decision of the edna committee to
make this happen having done their their
research i would just add that by moving
the board to the oplc
it would then be comparable to the way
other boards are
managed and the way that they conduct
themselves for example realtors and the
like thank you madam chair
seeing none
will the clerk call the role
on um
hb5552
otp
thank you madam chair representative
wyler yes
representative petri votes yes
representative emerick yes
thank you
ah representative irf yes
representative edwards no
representative
yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative norgren no
representative bucco no
representative leashman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers
represent no
walls no
representative heath no
representative murray no
yes
better share the vote on hp 1552 ought
to pass is eight yes 12 no
we missing one oh no i'm sorry nine nine
nine
hb
1552 on a vote of nine in favor and
twelve against the otp motion fails i
will entertain
an itl motion
uh you can't move unless you turn your
move that we move this bill itl thank
you do i have a second second
ready
okay well the clerk please call the roll
on the itl motion
thank you madam chair uh
representative wyler
no
we're jonathan burrish yes
president petrie votes
no
representative earth no
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner
no
representative lynn no
representative mooney
no
arizona turkon no
representative walner
yes
virgin orgrim yes
roberto bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers
yes
original walls yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
madam chair there's
12 yes eight no i'm i'm sorry nine
boy i'm missing you every time
on hb 1552 it'll okay
the vote on hb 1552
itl is 12 in favor 9 opposed
okay we'll now move
uh
who made the motion for that
okay
oh yeah
we could do consent but not on
okay um
we'll uh
okay
yes before we do anything i need to
figure out
um
who is going to do the majority report
i made the motion but i don't want to
write the report so if somebody wants to
write the report
pardon
all right that doesn't affect me
with an
and it has an amendment
1169. madam chair before we move into
that i i would would like to provide
some clarification to the committee
as as to staffing levels at the at the
corrections
oh sure uh thank you madam chair uh you
all received uh a page that looks like
this
uh in testimony at the work session
yesterday
a comment was made that corrections has
sixty percent vacancy rate
and uh we were all very humbled by that
uh
so
attorney
marcio from
corrections has provided this document
which shows by different operations what
the actual vacancy rate is
i mean it's still like 36 percent at the
men's prison but it's not 60 percent
which with the testimony from yesterday
which i heard repeated today so i just
wanted to clarify yes there is there's
vacancies but it's not as dire as it was
represented thank you madam chair
okay thank you very much for this uh
repsome emmerich
okay
uh could i have a motion
to
approve amendment
two to zero two two
so
thank you representative griffin do i
have a second
second okay seconded by representative
emrick
representative griffin do you want to
talk to your
motion on the amendment
thank you madam chair
i i
i think it's easier to refer the to the
document and let people read
man i'm sure i'd be glad to fill in some
of the blank spots okay please do but
bring your microphone up
thank you
uh what the amendment does the original
bill
uh was for group two
and the calculation of uh retirement
that was changed in
uh no
in 2011.
uh what the amendment does
and that well the basic bill
had a lot more information and it
changed a lot more things the amendment
addresses this calculation for group two
there are approximately 4 900 employees
in group 2.
this addresses the 1900 that were
affected by the calculation change as of
july
1st 2011
what this does is
restore
the calculation that those individuals
were hired under
anybody hired after that date
has the current calculations what this
does is is
i would say repair
what was a bad a good bad idea in 2011
that got us to this point so what we're
trying to do is make whole the
calculation for those employees that
were hired under a different calculation
set that got modified
so that's what basically the amendment
does is it narrows the scope from the
original bill
this does not have a fiscal note
uh it will have a fiscal note when it is
provided the other body because uh
retirement system actuarials uh only
provide fiscal notes on bills they don't
do it just on request
so this bill by the time it is is taken
up by the other body will have a fiscal
note the estimate of cost is somewhere
in the 28 to 30 million dollar range
but that's that's a that's a scientific
guess
thank you manager are you sure that's
not a swag it was a swag but i thought
i'd delete some of the words thank you
thank you are there any other comments
on the amendment uh representative waltz
thank you madam chair um i agree with
what uh chairman emmerich said but i
just wanted to clarify a little it
doesn't quite restore things back to the
way it was in 2000
before we messed with it in 2011
then it was the top three years this is
now the top five years so it's it's
still a bit of a differentiation but
it's closer to what we did but i wanted
to make it clear that it's not a full
clawback to what the law was before they
messed the legislature messed with it in
2011. it it gets us part of the way
there but not all the way there
thank you are there any further comments
madam chair uh i would concur
this is primary addressing the
calculation
represent edwards
uh so
so i'm just curious because i didn't sit
in on these meetings if if we have two
people who retired and two or were in
the system prior to 2011
and person a retires in 2019 person b
retires in 2024
does person a who retired in 2019 do
they see any change to their retirement
as a result of this bill
in the 2024 retiree
does does this essentially make that
person whole all the way back to 2011
with the distinction between the three
and five-year mark
my understanding of this bill addresses
people who are currently employed
i don't i don't believe this has
anything to do with people who had re
some of some of us were here during that
uh sb3 discussion
this is
for the people that were on the rolls
those are the people
that are
when they were they were on the rolls
but not vested
and so when they came on
they were
under the assumption
that
the retirement system
would be
what they thought when they came to work
here
and
the way the sb3 was written
you had to be vested
in order to maintain
your
retirement the way the way it was
and so what this does is it
takes care of the people
that were on board
hired
but not vested
and so that's
i think that it has nothing to do with
when you retire
it all has to do with when you were
hired
okay
there any further comments
i have a question if it's possible is
there a revised fiscal note that goes
with this the original fiscal note as
i'm reading it indicates a 50 roughly 56
million dollar cost in fy 23 is that
unchanged higher or lower
thank you bob chair
representative
there is not a revised fiscal note
the the revised fiscal note will be less
but we won't know until it's run through
retirement's
uh actuarial system
it's estimated to be somewhere in the 30
million dollar range
but it will there will be fiscal note
seeing none will the clerk call the role
on amendment 1169
thank you manager this house bill 1587
amendment 1169h
representative weiler
yes
president seberge yes president petrie
votes yes representative emrick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes representative turcotte yes
represent walner
yes
represent orgrim yes representative
bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes representative
walsh yes
representative heath
president murray yes representative
romberger yes
madam chair the vote on hp 1587
amendment 1169 h is 21-0 okay amendment
one one
two zero two two
one one six nine
passes on a vote of
21 to zero
could i now have an ought to pass as
amended motion so moved
representative griffin do i have a
second
swagman
got it okay
are there any is
seeing none will the clerk call the roll
and
it just on bill 1586 house bill 1587
fna
ought to pass as amended representative
wilder
yes
version of the burst
president petrie volch yes
representative emerick yes
representative earth no
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative murder yes
representative lynn yes
rosen mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative orgrim yes
rosanna bucco yes
arizona leashman yes
arizona patch yes
arizona rajesh yes
version of walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
burger
yes
madam chair of the vote on hb 1587 auto
pass as amended is 20 to 1.
thank you
hb 1587
relative to the determination of the
average final compensation under the
retirement system and making an
appropriation therefore
passes 20 to one
otpa
okay
we now move to division two
and you'll notice the clock says it's 7
30. that's am in case anyone was
concerned
if we move as fast on the rest of these
we'll be
all right um
returning now to division two
hb 1462
fn
relative to motorcycle learners permit
would you like to speak to your motion
yes very briefly um under current law
a motorcycle
or someone wanting to get a motorcycle
license is allowed to get a learner's
permit on a one-time basis
this bill would allow it to be renewed
one additional time
a testimony was given by the trainer who
operates the motorcycle
training
department at the d.o.t
and he gave actually some examples of
why this would be a good idea
um
there would be an additional fee
required
and extremely minimal uh reprogramming
costs involves so i recommend an ought
to pass on this
thank you uh
i believe that man is from safety
no you are correct not d.o.t you're
right safety you are correct okay thank
you just so that uh
we're not uh
charging d.o.t with motorcycle
requirements
they have enough to do
okay are there any further questions
comments
seeing none will the clerk call the roll
thank you madam chair this is on a host
bill 1462 fn
the motion is ought to pass
president weiler yes
representative burris yes president
petrie votes yes representative emerick
yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney
yes president turcotte yes resident
walner
yes
roseanne norgren yes
verizon leashman yes
president hatch yes
virgin rogers yes
president walsh yes
version of heath yes
rosanna murray yes
rosanna romberger
yes
madam share the vote on hp 1462.
uh hb 1462
passes uh 21
uh
there was a fee
so
and i think it was about twenty thousand
dollars in reprogramming costs something
okay
moving now to
hb
uh which is setting maximum containment
levels of
pfoas
that shows an otpa
that is how it passed the house floor
but
we only have otp to worry about
so could i have a motion
to um
so move madam chair thank you do i have
a second
represent mooney would you like to speak
to the bill
just briefly
thank you madam chair i know we did have
a question i don't know if you want to
take that first or no
maybe maybe you'll answer the question
thank you very much madam chair i'm the
prime sponsor of house bill 1547
and i have to say that this bill is the
result of extraordinary collaboration
between the citizens group merrimack
citizens for clean water
our merrimack house delegation our state
senator and the des in particular mr
wemsat who i see is here today in the
audience
as the bill first was introduced uh we
tried
almost
a little bit too prematurely to set
or standards for pollution in soil as a
result of pfas
as it turns out
there is a federal study that's going to
be conducted on soil
conducted by the united states
geological survey the usgs
that study is critical to the setting of
standards of pollution pfas pollution in
soils
this amended bill
and i might add is amended entirely
different from the way it was originally
introduced
the amended version recognizes that
study
recognizes the due date of that study
and then
basically uh says that the commissioner
would then set standards based on the
study
these are critical
pieces also in section two of the
amended version of the bill
it amends the groundwater protection act
to add soil
and that a person liable for such
contamination provide safe alternative
water to an impacted well owner
the word person i might add
includes corporations
public or private and companies
lastly the amended bill clarifies
language with regards to certain
hazardous waste generators
making our state standards consistent
with those on the federal standard which
i understand has been causing some
confusion this bill will clear that up
so the amended bill that came out of the
ena committee unanimously and then on
the consent calendar has a fiscal note
of no fiscal impact on the state
and i'll hope that was brief enough and
i would appreciate your support of an
ought to pass motion on this very
representative edwards uh representative
mooney addressed the question thank you
are there any further questions or
comments
i got to figure out whether this is otp
or otpa
otp yeah that's right
i thought because it passed that's right
okay
all right
hb 1547
otp
uh will clerk call the roll
thank you mayor chair
representative weiler yes president the
burris yes president petrie votes yes
representative emrick yes
representative erf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative murder yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative leashman yes
representative hatch yes
resident rogers yes
it was in the walls yes
original heath yes
roger murray yes and representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote on hb 1547 in otp
is 21-0
thank you
uh hb
uh
otp the vote is 21 to zero and it passes
is there anyone that
okay
the next bill is hb 1624
fn
relative to students with disabilities
participating in co-curricular
activities and making an appropriation
therefore
we have an amendment
66.
20 20 20 22
oh
okay
uh could i have a
motion
to accept
amendment two zero two two one one six
six so moved thank you do i have a
second
thank you
uh representative
i know that this is really your
amendment with my name on it
so um would you mind uh
simply discussing what uh what this does
absolutely madam chair actually just a
couple of very small amendments
um the original the original bill didn't
specify how much money could be devoted
to any one particular program uh so we
added in a
the amount of any grant shall be no more
than 4 000 per program and that gives
the department still a lot of latitude
on exactly how much they give to
each program if they get a uh you know a
lot of requests
they can reduce that number
uh but in no case can they
do more than four thousand uh the only
other part of the amendment was the
changing of the date the department had
asked for a little more time for
implementation
seeing none will the clerk call the roll
on amendment
2022-1166
thank you man chair uh house bill 1624
ought to pass
with amendment
president wilder
yes
president
yes president petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin
representative edwards yes
president bernard yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative uh norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
represent rogers yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
resident murray yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote on hb 1624 ought to
pass
the amendment 1166 h
is 21-0 thank you
the amendment
passes on a vote of
to zero
could i have a motion pleased on otpa
for hp
1624 fn so moved thank you represent
lynn
to have a second
thank you representative
turcotte may i speak to the motion you
may speak to the motion thank you so
this this bill amends rsa 21
and 4
by adding a new paragraph roman numeral
that requires the commissioner of
education to review and update on at
least an every other year basis
a consolidated state plan to establish
and encourage
unified co-curricular activities in
school districts unified co-curricular
activities are activities such as sports
music theater etcetera
that include
combined participation by both students
with disabilities or with special needs
and students without such conditions the
bill appropriates the sum of fifty
thousand dollars to the department of
education for the fiscal year ending
june thirtieth twenty twenty three for
the purpose of funding grants to school
districts
for year operational expenses for
equipment and or uniforms for such
programs and provides that any funds
remaining shall not lapse but may be
distributed as grants to schools to
school districts that already have
established unified co-curricular
activities
as as we've already discussed per the
amendment
no grant can exceed four thousand
dollars per program
the uh bill also requires the
commissioner to include in d.o in
department of education's efficiency
expenditure requests under rsa 94
sufficient funds for continued operation
of its duties
under the legislation the committee vote
on the uh
voted six to four in favor of the
amendment and i urge you to vote uh to
pass it as amended
thank you are there any further comments
or questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you on uh
hb 1624
otpa
thank you madam chair
uh
representative water
yes president the burris yes president
petrie votes yes representative emmerich
yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative murder
yes representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
president organ
and representative bucco yes
representative leashman yes
arizona hatch yes
yes representative rogers yes
version of walsh yes
reginald heath yes roger murray yes and
representative elmer
uh yes
matter of chair the vote on hb 1624
octopass is amended is 21-0
thank you uh the uh
hb 1624
as amended
so for fifty thousand dollars we have to
watch it
should we try for a roll rule rule
change
okay
we are now uh thank you we are now
moving to um hb
which has an amendment number
two zero two two
one one
six
three
could i have a motion on the amendment
uh madam chair i would like to move um
amendment 1163h
and i will speak to my amendment
okay do i have a second second
representative lynn seconds
representative heath
thank you madam chair um the amendment
to
house bill
1627 which establishes an education
freedom account program administer
administrator for the department of
education
does two things
first the amendment
reduces the amount of the allocation for
the full-time administrator it basically
prorates it to 115 000
and secondly
what this amendment does uh this was
actually um a non-germane
amendment
that uh came before us at a public
hearing
recently
amendment a portion of the amendment
is to a pr um
authorize the department of education to
apply to be part of a pilot program for
medicaid direct certification programs
this original thinking came out of a
committee that was a
committee that came out of division two
and house education it was a combined
committee
that we were looking at different um we
were concerned about the manner in which
free and reduced lunch counts were taken
and this was a result this came as a
recommendation and a result of that
committee that worked
on this
group
so
what it does is the
amendment will make
new hampshire it authorizes new
hampshire to apply to be part of this
demonstration project to evaluate direct
certification with medicaid
administration and it also authorizes
the department of education and the
department of health and human services
to work together and i would ask for
your support on this amendment please
as are to pass
yes go ahead represent turcotte
thank you madam chair um i i'll be
voting against this only because it came
potential monetary uh
factor involved
um that is unknown at this time which
could be uh fairly expensive so on the
representative heath did you want to
respond
um
in terms of
the cost that would be associated this
um
i
actually
did it's a pilot program
and
i think the
ultimate
would be a benefit
to the children of new hampshire
in that we will better identify the
number of students who will be eligible
for free and reduced lunch and i think
we all know that that children
who eat breakfast and lunch have
improved academic performance reduce
behavior problems
they have fewer trips to the nurses
office and they have better attendance
in school and in terms of school
districts this will really be a plus for
them because we will reduce the
paperwork that they need to um uh
gather on a yearly basis
so there actually there are 27 other
states participating in this process and
as the research has shown significant
positive results so um that would be my
response to your comment sir
thank you very much are there other
comments on the amendment
seeing none
will the clerk call the role on
amendment
2022-116
thank you madam chair uh representative
weiler
yes
president the burris yes
original petri votes yes representative
emerick yes
representative earth no
representative griffin no
representative edwards no
representative mirner
yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative walner yes
representative
yes
representative bucco yes
representative leashman yes
oh i'm sorry
okay so representative rogers
yes
reginald walsh yes
version of heath yes
president murray yes
representative berger yes
manager of the vote is
to 4.
on hb
otp
on amendment
2 2022 1163 h
thank you the amendment passes
1163 on a vote of 16 to 4.
uh could i please have an ought to pass
as amended motion
madam chair i would like to move hb 1627
as amended ought to pass
second
okay yeah okay well the clerk please
call the roll
all right this song house bill 1627
ought to pass as amended
representative wilder yes
version of the burris yes
representative petry volch yes
representative emrick yes
representative irf no
representative griffin no
representative edwards yes
there's a representative murder
yes
representative glenn yes representative
mooney
yes
representative walner
representative organ yes
rosano bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
he's not here
representative rogers yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
and representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote on hb 1627 ought to
pass as amended is
to 3. okay
hb 1627
otpa
thank you
absolutely yeah
okay
um
well now oh uh represent heath you have
uh
the blurb
all right uh we're now moving to hb
[Music]
and we have an amendment on that
of
okay could i have a motion please uh on
the amendment
representative murray i'm so moved thank
second okay represent lynn seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
motion represent murray sure thank you
madam chair this is a non-german
amendment that came to us to address an
emergency situation regarding the stores
street parking garage
it's well past its lifespan
and um
it's been discussed for years whether or
not what we need to do with the store
street garage
it would appear that
minor injuries
to individuals using that garage have
been growing in frequency over the past
couple of years trippings and scrapes
and bruises and bumps
i took special note driving in today to
look at the netting and netting to me
seems to be kind of a euphemism this is
like really hard stuff
to keep chunks of the stores street
garage from falling onto the first floor
platform or falling onto a car or a
person walking on that platform also
from chunks falling onto the road below
so this came to us as an emergency
situation that we
need to deal with instead of kicking it
down the road which apparently we have
been doing for a while um
the amendment
request or suggests that it does more
than suggest asks that the store street
garage
be demolished
a new structure be constructed at the
site of the current department of
justice building which would also be
raised
and that the department of justice be
moved to another location
and there is a place where they can go
they've already considered where they
would put justice
given that this has been a problem for a
long time the building
we are spending apparently several
million dollars a year to keep it at
least functional um perhaps
your version of safe is not necessarily
the same as other people's version of
safe but we are sure that it is safe
right now but it is costing a
significant amount of money every year
in order to maintain that position
so this amendment came to us to make the
request as an appropriation of 35
million dollars i know it always stings
to spend money like that especially when
there are needs around the state but in
this instance the government needs has a
strong need too
so i request your support
on this amendment to address the store
street garage by removing that garage
removing the building um that is located
at the department of justice building a
new structure there and uh relocating
the department of justice with regards
to specifications um that is down in the
future so i cannot speak to exactly at
all what this would look like but i
please ask your support for this
amendment it is something we need to do
now we have reached the point of an
emergency
thank you are there any other comments
questions
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair and and thank you um
i i can imagine it's a it's a crisis and
we have to act now i would just like to
ask um
did the capital budget process break
because we didn't catch this earlier in
a capital budgeting process and if so
how did that process break down
you know
i don't know um if this can be laid to
the capital budget process or not
i think that it's simply it's risen to
the level of an emergency and putting it
through the capital budget process at
this point would not be appropriate i
can't speak to why we did not do this
10-15 years ago so
okay
okay so my follow-up on that isn't that
i'm i have no argument that it's a
crisis and we have to do this now i'm
just asking you know given that this is
such a
obvious item that should be in the
capital budget do we know why it wasn't
included in the capital budget process
and i think i heard your answer to be no
we don't know
uh representative weiler can shed some
light on this
yes the uh chairman of public works got
up to say
that there's about a hundred million in
the capital
uh budget every year and this would
would just kill all her other so many
other projects that he didn't think it
was appropriate to put it in the capital
budget because it would
kind of reduce all her other work so
he's hoping that there's enough money
and surplus that we can do it out of
that so we don't have to get involved in
the capital budget that was his
testimony thank you
uh
the other thing is that
until
relatively recently like this year
or
a year ago whatever but relatively
recently
is the first time that anyone has
actually put anything together
as to the cost of
uh replacing the store street garage
we've talked about it for
10 years
minimum
i was on a committee in 2005 to build a
parking garage right there so that's
more than 10 years
so it just never really
got off the ground
in the past to where it could even be
considered
by
um
the uh
capital budget
and i think that ken's point or sorry
representative weiler's point about
uh
trying to um
bond this through the capital budget
would really
be a significant problem for
the rest of the needs of the state so
did you have a further question
i i did i i think the only reason i'm
going to vote no on this obvious need is
that i it just feels to me like the
capital budgeting process ought to have
routine replacement of buildings
included and if we don't have enough
money in it then we should be
showing an unfunded uh
balance in the capital budget
requirements so i i just i'm going to
vote no just because i think this was a
broken process and even though i know we
need to do it
thank you
are there any other comments
seeing none
will the clerk call the role on
amendment two zero two two
one one seven
three
thank you matter chair uh
voting ought to pass on 1173h to bill hb
1661.
representative weiler yes
president
yes president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
legend earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards no
representative murder yes
representative lynn
yes original mooney
yes
representative
representative walner
yes
represent an organ yes
original puco yes
arizona leashman
peter is that because you don't park
down there representative hatch
i'm very reluctant yes
yes
representative rogers yes
representative walsh yes
version of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the vote on hb 1661
amendment 1173 h
is 20 to 1.
thank you h
passes on a vote of
20 to 1.
uh
could i please have a motion on hb
as amended
so moved madam thank you representative
murray do i have a second
okay representative heath
thank you
are there any further
comments
questions
okay
well the clerk called the roll
thank you madam chair uh representative
weiler this is i'm sorry this is uh hb
ought to pass as amended
representative weiler yes
representative burris yes president of
petrie votes yes representative emerick
yes
representative irf yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards
yes
representative murder yes
representative flynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
president walter
yes
representative
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
rosanna murray yes
and representative humber
yes madam chair the vote on h.b 1661
ought to pass as amended is 21-0
thank you
hp 1661
passes
otpa
on a vote of 21 to zero
i guess that's not consent
yeah let's put it on consent yeah all
right get that one boy
oh you people are
okay
uh
hb
1665 establishing a municipal road and
bridge disaster relief fund
is not did not come out of committee
it came out of committee
as a recommendation for
interim study
so if you're
interested in correcting your
papers
that's the way we are so
could i have a motion for interim study
on hb 1665
thank you madam chair i moved that hb
be um
interim studied please thank you do i
represent turcotte seconds
are there would you like to speak to
your motion
i would like madam q to speak to my um
motion
um
this bill is a terror well it's not a
a good bill
but
my concern is
what it means um during our hearing
this bill is really about um a
natural disaster occurring in a town and
what happens after that disaster takes
place
um and the question i asked i said you
know god forbid if for some reason a
hurricane or a tornado went through my
city of manchester what resources would
be immediately available to that my town
um and
right away there isn't anything we we do
have
a piece of legislation
chapter 9 um under um
9 colon 13-d
that is civil emergency and it it
provides the governor
with the authority to go to fiscal
committee but you know and i know how
long it takes to get the fiscal
committee that would be at least a two
week turnaround so
in the event of all said what happened
was the the
damage was so severe that the roads were
closed um they they needed to repair the
bridge and the road and they needed to
get it opened right away and for that
they there was nothing available to them
now while this bill was not a good bill
i thought that
probably maybe entertaining some kind of
a conversation about what help is
available
and to set up a meeting or a study group
with
homeland security about what could we do
in the state of new hampshire to make
sure that we don't leave
our towns and municipalities
that especially the small small ones
that are the most vulnerable and don't
have much money immediately to make some
of these changes austed had to take out
a loan for 2.2 million dollars so that's
the reason why i'm asking for your
support on this bill i mean otherwise i
would probably say it just should be itl
because it's not a good bill on its
merit but it's the the
um
situation itself when we see what's
happening with the weather across the
country that if in fact something we did
have some kind of a
disaster that we needed to address that
that we would have something in place
thank you
just clarification is it allstead or
acworth backworth
all right i i just i know the
representative and she's very proud of
yeah else did had one before yes
yes
okay
uh seeing no further comments uh will
the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh the bill is
host bill 1665
fna local
the motion is interim study
representative weiler
yes
uh representative petry votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes
arizona griffin yes representative
edwards yes
representative mirner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
yes
rosita norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
resident walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative uh murray yes
president umberger
yes
madam chair the voter in hb 1665 is
interim study and the vote is 20 to
nothing
thank you
um hb 1665
interim study
passes on a vote of 20 to 0.
i think we can probably put this on the
consent calendar
are there any objections
okay
we now move to hb 1682
establishing the law enforcement conduct
review committee
in new hampshire police standards and
training council and making an
appropriation thereof
we have an amendment
2022-1099
could i have a motion on the amendment
so moved will we uh uh pass the
amendment okay do i have a second oh
sure lynn representative representative
okay
uh would you like to speak to your
motion
yes
in the interest of of efficiency if if i
may speak to the to the underlying bill
also i'm i'm happy to answer any
questions
no okay well then this then this
amendment in this inefficient way i'm
sorry okay
uh this amendment uh proposes to change
the original bill's
appropriation of three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to one hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars
because the monies
uh
uh the 350 000 was really anticipated
for the biennium and we only have a year
we only have a year it's only needed for
a year so it basically cuts the
appropriation in half
thank you are there any further comments
questions
seeing none
yeah thank you madam chair uh this is on
house bill 1682 fna
ought to pass the amendment is 20 22
1099 h
representative weiler
yes
president the burris
he's not here representative petry
votes yes
i had to think
who am i representative america yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney yes
president turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative
representative yes
arizona leashman yes
president hatch yes
and representative rogers yes
president waltz yes
president of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative von berger
yes
veteran chair of the vote on it hb 1682
art is on uh on amendment 2022 1099 h is
20 22 1099
is 20 to 0 the amendment passes
uh
okay could i please have a motion on hb
s one six eight two
otpa
it's all moved thank you do i have a
separate shoe lynn okay represent lynn
thanks who who's that
i missed that i missed i miss i missed a
okay
would uh you like to comment now sure
thank you thank you madam chair uh yes
this this uh bill the the underlying
bill now as amended um uh represents the
um
the uh legislation to uh
basically enact a number of the
recommendations of the lee act uh
commission
specifically the bill establishes a law
enforcement conduct review committee in
the new hampshire police standards and
training council
um
it reduces the
appropriation and as we've already voted
on but the
it establishes a comprehensive
definition of what constitutes police
misconduct and establishes procedures
for filing complaints
review and investigation of the
complaints holding hearings before the
council to adjudicate complaints and
sanctions that may be imposed for
misconduct by officers um the committee
voted uh five to oh the
subcommittee voted five to oh in favor
of the amendment and i urge you to uh
vote at otp as amended
any
further comments
you have a question
um go ahead represent edwards thank you
madam chair
um
it seems to me that we probably have had
some kind of a law enforcement conduct
review
process in the past is is this
is this a brand new thing we're doing or
or or is this augmenting something that
we think could work better
well there
it's more than augmenting i mean there
there has been a a law enforcement
you know misconduct uh process of
investigation it's been
i think our our understanding is it's
been in the past not very
standardized so there's much there's
been much
discrepancies between departments
in terms of how it's handled
um
uh
and and in terms of what i mean for
example one of the things that this bill
does is i think is very important is
define what constitutes police
misconduct um the the information we
received was that you know various
police departments in various places in
the state have interpreted what kind
what may constitute misconduct
significantly differently among each
other so i think that's one of the big
things that this does
thank you representative thank you madam
chair
okay are there any other questions
comments
seeing none will the clerk call the role
please
thank you madam chair uh this is on
house bill 1682 fna ought to pass as
amended
representative wilder yes
president
yes
representative petry
mulch yes
representative emerick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes president
murder yes
representative lin yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
representative norgren yes
representative yes
representative leishman yes
arizona hatch yes
representative rogers yes representative
walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes representative omburger
yes
madam chair the vote is on h.b 1682 fna
is ought to pass as amended and the vote
thank you hb 1682
as amended otpa passes
21 to 0.
so
i'm going to take liberty here and ask
us to
stand up for about 10 minutes
so that we can
stretch our legs
and do whatever else might be
appropriate
madam chairman
i can't go on the guy yes is it your
intent not to take a lunch break is that
it
uh yes because i know that these
division three bills are going to just
sail right through
okay thank you
yeah okay so i think you would fire the
clerk yeah you don't even know his own
name
whatever executive session back to order
okay um
during our little break and stretch
um
the lba has passed out three amendments
so
we turn now to hb 1526
relative to income eligibility for in
and out medical assistance
madam chair i'd like to move an
amendment to
1526 uh amendment 22
second
okay seconded by uh
uh
oh uh would you like to speak to your
amendment please uh please i um this
amendment
uh if you if you read it it says that it
would appropriate
1.342 million
that would be for the final quarter of
the second fiscal
second year of this fiscal budget cycle
the bill came to us with four times that
amount of money to cover the entire
second year of the budget
what we came to understand to have
happened
was somewhere in the budget process
uh the other house
suspended um
the process under which they
used income eligibility
for in and out medical assistance and so
what this bill does
is it
restores
um the the prior authorizations and then
uh okay thank you are there any comments
questions
okay
15 26 amendments well that's because
we're going to vote on this one and then
representative wallner is going to
okay will the clerk please call the roll
thank you mayor chair uh this vote is on
hb 1526 fn
ought to pass on amendment 2022 1121 h
representative wilder yes
president
yes
president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
representative mirner
yes representative glenn yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcot yes
representative walner
yes
representative morgan yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
version of hatch yes
president rogers yes
original walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
founder of chair the vote on hb
is uh ought to pass no no no we're
voting on the amendment only yeah i was
getting to that
is 11 11 21 h right
okay the vote is 21 to zero
the amendment two zero two two dash
[Music]
h
passes on a
21-0 vote
and representative walner i believe you
have
an amendment that you want to uh
introduce at this time i do thank you um
madam chair
so as you heard
this
the remedy for this problem of in and
out medical assistance i'm sorry what
was your amount um what amendment we
talked about we're talking about uh
2022-11818
thank you
walner's at the top of that one
so as you heard this program
did not um end up getting into the
budget
and um it seems like it was
sort of an oversight or something happen
these these folks have not had
an increase in their
eligibility for i believe we were told
30 years
and
these are very very low income people
who go in and out of
medicaid
and getting medical assistance with
their
bills many of them are people with
mental illness
and they need
what my amendment does is fund it for
six months
representative edwards did it for three
i just feel like they have been left
behind for so long
and they got inadvertently left out of
the budget um
during this last budget period so
it was sort of a middle ground
uh thank you representative walner um i
did not get a second
okay uh swallower uh edwards
okay thank
you all right um is there anyone else
that wants to speak to this
representative edwards
uh uh thank you madam chair um
i i
i don't have any opposition to this the
uh the my amendment came first in the
process and and in talking to
representative walner i i believe that
triggered her thinking that she would
submit this one
um
and
the reason i picked a quarter
was predominantly out of a perception
that we had a limited amount of money to
apply
in this cycle and i didn't know how much
it was and so i figured a quarter was a
parsimonious way to get something and
not just nothing so
um so i i'm not opposed to the walnur
amendment
thank you are there any other
seeing none
uh will the clerk call the role on
amendment
202211818
thank you madam chair representative
weiler no
representative
yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative uh emrick yes
representative erf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
rosanna lynn
yes
representative mooney
representative
no
representative wallner
yes
version of norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
rosanna walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
madame chair on hb 1526
amendment 1181 h
is 19 to 2.
okay the vote
is uh
on amendment
2022-1181
h is
so so madam chair i'd like to make a
motion
okay
representative griffin
uh thank you madam chair my question is
does that wipe out the earlier amendment
well that's just what i was trying to
figure out but i think it does but i
think we have to eliminate the other
amendment
my motion would be otp opta with
amendment 1181
and and then that if we voted on that
okay
so the
do i have a second for that motion
second
representative emrick so it was emmerich
edwards
okay thank you
all right so the motion before us is
hb1526
as amended
eight 2022-1181
yes you may
oh okay so i think this is uh fairly
obvious i we just we just passed one
that lasts a longer period of time with
the walnut amendment
and uh this is a population of need i'd
also add that we get federal matching
money as a result of this
so um i i i'm in favor of 1181
and and not the uh earlier one i i
proposed okay thank you very much
represent lynn yes just really a
question for representative which can
you or or representative walnut can you
just sort of explain to me or a little
more detail what the in and out program
really is how
how it works and who it captures uh
we were given the information that there
are right now about 2500
um
people with mental illness that are on
this program
and about
3600 that fall into the area of
elderly disabled or blind
they're low-income people who whose
incomes are not
not low enough to be on state assistance
but they have such a large spin down
for
health
related costs
that their that their incomes drop
way below what they're uh way below the
eligibility for state assistance
so it's a monthly program so when on
months that they have a lot of expenses
they can get
some
medical help on months that they don't
they have to cover
all of their own cost
and i'm
far from an expert in it and i hope i've
not messed this up okay
but that's my understanding of how it
works um
but these are very very meaty
meaty um
uh representative edwards thank you i i
i concur with what representative walner
just said and i i would just add that
the uh the folks that benefit most from
this are in chronic care conditions
because they end up
due to their medical spend dropping
below the eligibility levels uh
frequently within a year so uh this this
helps people these help our poorest
thank you both
and just to clarify a little bit further
this is each month so their income is is
above the medicaid level they start
buying their drugs they hit the medicaid
and they pay the money they get down to
the medicaid level now medicaid picks it
up next month process starts over again
they start having to spend their money
they hit the medicaid level medicaid
picks up so a month-to-month basis
they're basically spending money out of
pocket and then medicaid picks up a
little bit and then it starts over again
the next month so the right on the
border line of the medicaid
threshold
you know i'm can i ask just one
follow-up so am i understanding what
you're saying that that the money that
we're
paying is the money that when they do
hit the medicaid threshold this is the
money this is our portion so to speak of
the money that is expended for medicaid
representative durf i'm not sure if
you're asking about the money in the
bill or the money in general
the money in general i'm sorry so
essentially this will raise the
threshold so they will no longer be in
that going back and forth they'll be on
medicaid
thank you
okay
everybody clear on that no
but
yes
yeah i have uh i have never heard of
medicaid in and out before but
i have now
yeah
okay
so um
will the clerk call the role on
hb
1526 as amended by
very good thank you madam chair uh
representative weiler yes representative
burris yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative emrick yes
representative erf yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
representative
yes
representative lane yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
buco yes
representative leashman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
representative walsh yes
arizona heath yes
representative murray yes representative
hamburger
yes
madam chair the vote on hb
1526 as amended by
1181 h amendment is 21-0
thank you
hb
is approved with a vote of 21 to zero
we now turn to hb 1531
which modifies the oversight commission
on children's services
could i have a motion please madam uh
chair i'd like to move otp
thank you do i have a second second
second by
representative erf
represent edwards did you want to
comment on this uh yes ma'am this is uh
this is one of three bills we're going
to talk about today where um
between the time that the
policy committee amended it and the time
there was a realization that the uh
fiscal note no longer applied and so it
didn't have a fiscal impact and in those
three cases this being the first one
today uh we'll just uh put it otp
and put it on consent so since there's
no financial issue
and i can i can speak to the bill but
it's almost irrelevant that's fine
uh are there any questions
seeing none
[Music]
will the clerk call the role on
otp
for hb
1531.
thank you mayor chair
representative weiler yes
president of the bridge yes version
petri votes yes representative amrit yes
representative irf yes representative
griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative mariner yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney yes
representative yes
representative walner
yes
roger norgren
yes arizona buco yes
representative leashman yes
arizona hatch yes
rosanna rogers yes
representative walsh yes representative
heath yes
representative murray yes representative
hamburger yes
when we share the vote on hb 1531 out to
pass is 21-0
thank you hp 1531 otp
passes on a vote of 21
to zero
is there any objection to placing this
on the consent calendar
seeing none
okay we now turn to hb
including state medical facilities in
the statute
providing medical freedom in
immunizations
madam chairman i make a motion
we have an amendment
uh 1160.
uh could i have a motion on the
amendment please yes man i'm sure i'd
okay do i have a second
okay would you like to speak to your
motion uh thank you madam chair um
uh as
as the bill came over to division three
we had a significant concern
because um
we didn't want to put the state in
jeopardy of having cms withhold
medicaid money from us between the
medicaid money and money to nursing
homes about 160 million a year was at
stake
so what this amendment does
is it
keeps us on the right side of the bright
line uh and and and keeps the funding
secure
what this amendment does is um
uh the first thing
it does is what it doesn't do it it
deleted
the uh
write a conscience as a way to
seek an exemption
cms doesn't recognize that so so this
amendment deletes the right of
conscience
then on the medical exemption
uh we made it very clear that we're
going to be following the documentation
requirements of cms to apply for a
medical exemption and so that that puts
us into conformance
and then
the the third thing which may be the
biggest thing and the thing the primary
sponsor likes
is that it establishes
the uh
religious exemption in our law such that
uh an individual can go to their
employer
and do a self-attestation that they have
a sincerely um held religious belief
and it
effectively
takes the employer
out of the mode of
judging whether or not it's a real
religious belief
the you know federal government
is there to protect freedom of religion
and it should not be delegating power to
an employer to sit in judgment of an
individual's religious belief they're
not qualified it's not part of their hr
department so so what this does is
because the cms rules say that there
must be an evaluation process by the
employer
we specify in this bill that the
evaluation process consists of
validating that the person is uh
legitimately covered by the policy that
they're using the appropriate form
that they've signed and dated
it
uh and then their obligations as part of
the evaluation effort is to go ahead and
put a date time stamp on it store the
record for at least a year
and um and then the the most evaluative
part is they can deny it if they have
um
uh reasons to believe strong reasons to
believe that there may be fraud at place
and filing the request
so
so this gives us
a clear religious exemption um that we
we didn't have before so i would ask you
to accept this amendment uh
that effectively replaces the the body
of 1604.
thank you are there any other com reps
in lynn yes just a question with regard
with regard to paragraph
e2 the last paragraph on the page the
only question i have is i didn't
i i didn't see any language in there
that says
that requires the employer to either
accept or either approve or deny the
request and i'm just wondering if that's
does does that need to be in there
um
okay i
i think that's a fair point i thank you
i
i believe it's covered because it says
the written requests for a medical
exemption shall include documentation as
required by cms
and then on line 24 it reads that the
employer shall evaluate the request to
ensure that the individual submitting is
so
so i i think the fact that they do
evaluate it and that they've been given
the guidelines of the medical
documentation required by cms i i think
it covers the the um
the evaluation requirement for the
employer but i i would defer to your uh
judgments you've done this longer than i
have
you know i guess the only question i
mean if it if the
if the medicaid
regulations sort of say
that you know if you submit certain docu
if you submit appropriate documentation
then the
the the
the uh
you know the exception shall be allowed
or something i think then i think i
would agree with you if it if it's open
if it doesn't really say anything then i
i you know that might be an issue but
presumably that could be corrected you
know by the other body
i i think so and i i will admit i did
not read the cms uh language on this
specifically
but i got good counsel advice by
people who do
dabble in this and and
they thought this would be adequate
are there any further comments or
questions yes represent waltz
you know when i hear this it seems to me
that we're just inviting fraud i mean i
i could sit here and say you know i'm a
member of the church of tree frogs and i
don't believe in vaccinations you know i
mean
we i think we have a responsibility to
require at least some basic
uh
something that can be said with a
straight face
and this does not do that and that's my
concern
would you like to respond represent
edwards
thank you i i think we're in an era
where we've just generally accepted the
ability of people to self-identify in
the way that they choose to
self-identify
and given that religious freedom is
explicitly part of our constitution i
just don't think the government is in a
position to evaluate whether or not it's
a truly held religious belief
particularly when people can
self-identify as almost anything and
have their pronouns changed it just
seems to me that we ought to extend that
level of tolerance to the religious
community
thank you
representative waltz
but we as a government do question those
things if you want to claim to be a
conscientious objector for the military
purposes you have a pretty high bar to
prove it it's not unusual for the
government to want to see some serious
proof that this is a genuine belief from
a real religion and i'm not sure what
the distinction is between say the
military requiring it and i was just
accepting this and me and my tree frog
religion i mean what's the difference
here
okay go ahead
i i think this is just going to be one
of those areas in which
different principles
clash and don't fit together very well
but
given that some self-identity is
identified in the constitution as being
protected and yet we're extending
self-identity and pronouns to people who
don't find that protection in the
constitution specifically i i i think
that it's perfectly appropriate for us
to respect and tolerate the
individuality and religious beliefs of
others
thank you
represent turcotte
i i will support this amendment but i
will point out that i i think there are
some inconsistencies uh between this
bill and some other bills that we've
passed in the uh in the house i do like
how we you have um
a delineated rather wealthy religious
exemption
i i am not a fan that the right of
conscience has been removed only because
for those individuals who don't have a
religion or don't have a medical
reason a right of conscience
for some of us is can be almost equated
since we do have other bills in the
hopper um i i will support this if it
hadn't been for some of those other
bills i wouldn't but i will support this
amendment
i don't think so
uh representative petry
will you please call the role on
amendment
20221160h
thank you madam chair
representative weiler yes
president
yes president petri volchies
representative emerick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney yes
president turcotte yes
representative walner
no representative norgren no
representative bucco no
representative hatch no
representative rogers
no
representative walsh no
representative heath no
representative murray
no
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote on
thank you
uh hb 1604 amendment
2022 1160
you make a motion man i'm trying uh i
need a motion of otpa on 1604
yes amended by 1160 yeah i i'm so move
did you have a need to speak
it was it was a second
so so there's really nothing further to
say because this amendment uh
overwrites and replaces uh most of 1604
so we i think we just had the debate on
it
okay thank you is there any anyone else
that would like to comment
almost almost okay take your time no
we're good
all right um
representative weiler
yes
arizona for burris yes
president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes president
burner yes
representative flynn yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
no representative norgren no
representative bucco no
representative leashman yes
that was a yes
it was a yes
very good thank you
representative rogers no
representative walls no
representative heath no
representative murray no
representative
yes
madam chair the vote is 13 to 8
on hb 1604 ought to pass as amended
thank you hb 1604
on a vote of 13 to eight
we prove otp a
all right so now we move to hb
is that concern
oh
no i can't put it on consent with that
vote just a question
thank you
we now move to oh we now move to uh hb
relative to withdrawal from state
immunization registry
and it is otp
uh representative edwards uh
yes ma'am i moved 1608 otp and i can
speak to that
after a second second seconded by
representative edwards thank you madam
chair this is the second of the three
that
after it got amended by the policy
committee it came over to us and um
recognizing it has no fiscal impact uh
we recommend that it go uh otp from the
committee and then go on the consent
calendar
thank you are there any comments
questions from anyone
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
thank you madam chair uh this is on hb
1601 oh i'm sorry 08
fn
the motion is ought to pass
representative weiler
yes
representative burris yes represent
petrie votes yes representative emrick
yes
representative eric yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mariner yes
representative flynn yes representative
mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
represent organ yes
representative bucco yes representative
leishman yes
representative hatch
no
representative walls yes
roger heath no
representative murray yes
representative
yes
ma'am chair of the vote on hb 1608 ought
uh without objection i will put this on
the consign calendar
okay
we now move to hb 1609
relative to the scope of fetal
protection act
uh the recommendation is itl could i
have a motion please
uh man i'm sure i'd like to move 1609
itl
second
where'd that come from
uh would you like to speak to your
1609 has two significant uh financial
issues tied to it
um the
the
most obvious to people
is that it institutes a reporting
requirement and uh authorizes the money
to pay for it
um it's been the policy
of the house for for a few years now to
not collect abortion statistics so that
would violate the
basically uh truths that we have on the
issue
and and so i i would not want to support
the money to pay for the reporting um
because i think that would be an act of
bad faith the the other part of this
is that
this bill effectively guts the language
in
hb2 relative to the fetal protection act
and
there were probably three really
critical things that needed to
be agreed to
by the majority
in order to get the budget passed the
prior two terms we did not get a budget
passed on the first go around we
succeeded this time
and it was due to
looking each other in the eye and making
agreements and finding out what we could
agree to agree on
and so
given that
the finance committee made these
promises i think the finance committee
is obligated to keep those promises
because it's less than a year after we
did those agreements and we're just
about 14 15 months from needing
agreements again
and so you can only lose your integrity
and and credibility once
so i i do not want to support 1609 and
and go down the road of not being
trusted in the future and violating a
commitment made in the past so
i recommend itl
uh represent walner
thank you
i believe that the
fiscal impact of this bill is is really
very minor
and this came to us from the policy
committee
and by doing an itl we have rejected
completely what the policy committee has
sent to us
and i for that reason will be voting
thank you are there any other comments
questions
seeing none
will the clerk call the role
thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair uh this is on hb
1609 fn
the motion is itl
representative weiler yes
representative burris no
representative petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative murder yes
representative mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
arizona walnut
no
representative norgren no
arizona bucco no
representative leishman no
representative hatch no
representative uh rogers no
regional walls no
representative heath no
representative murray no
arizona umberger
yes
madam chair of the vote on hb 1609 to
itl is 10
uh the motion fails do i have another
motion may i make a point of order to to
understand that where we're at yep
okay so
obviously the next motion needs to be an
otp
in that circumstance can i offer an
amendment i have prepared and i can hand
out
uh
we need to have an otp motion before we
can do that
actually madam chair
uh if we could have a just a repeat of
the vote my numbers and i try to keep
track myself didn't quite add up to the
clerks
we did
yeah
there's
right
okay
uh so i have uh walnut
and do i have a second
okay uh would you like to speak to your
motion
oh you're right
no
don't
okay
yes the bill is now open for amendments
uh madam chair i'd like to introduce an
amendment uh mr ripple is handing it out
now
do you have the amendment number uh i
one one nine zero hotel
yes do i have a second on the amendment
second
okay
uh represent edwards would you like to
speak to your motion please
uh thank you madam chair um what
amendment eleven eleven nine zero or one
one nine zero does
is
it it
amends
the exceptions
under which
an abortion is permissible
after 24 weeks by adding
that
in the case of fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life
or
a medical emergency
so
the fetal abnormalities incompatible
with life
deals with those scenarios of public
concern
where uh
the mother finds out that the child's
survivability
is
is really very low
and it provides
the option of an abortion i i think in
most cases
the safer medical procedure at that
point is to go ahead and deliver the
child
but that's really a medical choice that
we would be leaving
to the mother and her physician by
creating this fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life option
and then the other thing it does
is
the hb2 language
already
made it clear
that
the ultrasound requirement was really
only going to be subject to penalty
if the provider
did not adequately back up their 24-week
determination there was there was never
a case where at 8 weeks or ten weeks
that we were mandating a medical
or an obstetric ultrasound and in order
to make the law clear
we've added the following phrase to
paragraph one
saying this paragraph shall be construed
to require the performance of an
ultrasound only if the provider either
knows that the fetus has a gestational
age of at least 24 weeks or is conscious
of a substantial risk that the fetus has
a gestational age of at least
24 weeks
so
i think this bill
this amendment addresses
most
of the concerns uh of many um to include
myself i think this is really good
policy
and it's something that i'd be i'm i'm
proud to offer this amendment
so
i i would ask for your support
and i'm wondering if i should keep tap
dancing until our chairman comes back
um
if you have anything further you keep
wanna and and then representative eric
has has it come okay i i would i would
just say that this this basically i
think uh has been coordinated with
enough people prior to this meeting that
uh we're not this this this would not
represent a break in good faith with the
people that we made our initial budget
agreement with
we worked very hard to talk to a lot of
people
and and this
this i think
can be acceptable to the majority in the
house that's my belief
uh representative lynn i'm i'm happy to
let you talk a little bit i i'm not the
chair so are you the chair now
representative
i believe there was a drafting error on
olessa's part
the in section one
the fetal abnormalities in competitive
life
phrase
um should not have been there that
phrase is actually in section two
except in the case of fetal
abnormalities compatible life or a
medical emergency i specified
okay so uh obviously as you know mr
ripple for lba coordinates this with ols
and when he and i talked about it
yesterday it's ols's recommendation that
representative lin for a comment thank
you i i um i
i guess i would have been i would have
been inclined the same way with
representative earth but if they if
there's reasons i i that's not a big
deal for me but um i would like to thank
you representatives for this for this
amendment i think
um
to me
this this amendment is is
crucial and and makes all the difference
in the world if i could i'd like to just
make four brief points
first to me
this amendment corrects a significant
two significant flaws in the current
fetal life protection act
and i want to i also want to say here
i'm very grateful to the governor's
office for the for inputs that they've
that they've provided on this
first the fetal abnormalities
inconsistent with life it seems to me is
critically important for the for the
reasons that you pointed out um
that was the reason that i've personally
i voted against h.b 16
it seems to me that in that situation of
a fetal abnormality inconsistent with
life it is just too much for the
government to step in and say you will
have the baby that just seems to me we
that that's a decision for the mother
um and secondly i think as you pointed
out also it corrects to the extent there
could have been any misunderstanding of
of the ultrasound requirement this
language it seems to me corrects it
um the other two points that i unders as
i understand that people have have sort
of
complained about the current fetal life
protection act it seems to me that i i
don't think that those criticisms are
well taken first of all to the extent
that that the original 1609 before this
amendment
um
adds as the la as the word health in
certain places
um and the claim has been that the
current law does not have a health
exception that is just that is just
wrong if you read the last clause
of our of current rsa
329 44 roman numeral 3
it clearly does that clearly does
constitute a health exception
it is a restricted health exception it
it means for example that there needs to
be some some significant risk to a
substantial to an important bodily
function
but the current 1609 without this
amendment where it simply says health
that i i think really would
significantly undermine the current law
it would basically say that if somebody
says you know i'm i will be really
depressed if i have to have this baby
that would be enough to say then you
don't then you're entitled to have an
abortion beyond the 24 weeks and
secondly to the extent that the um that
the criticism has been there is no uh
there's no uh
rape or incest exception again i would
take issue with that
the very fact that you have 24 weeks to
make that the woman has 24 weeks to make
that decision our own it seems to me
that really it that really covers that
certainly if somebody's been been raped
they they know on that when it happened
that they've been raped and they have
six months basically to make the
decision whether to have an abortion or
not and the last point i would make for
number four is simply
to the extent that there's been
criticism about the fact that the bill
that the current law has a penalty
provision
uh that that subjects doctors to
criminal penalties i think it's really
important to understand that there is no
danger of doctors being inadvertent of
inadvertently becoming criminals because
the current law has this very specific
men's rear requirement that provides
that before a doctor can be convicted he
has to act or he or she has to act
either knowing that he's performing an
abortion on a 20 on a post 20 or 24 or
post
fetus or consciously disregards that
doesn't mean it's enough to say the
doctor should have known that's not
enough the doctor has to actually have
known or have consciously disregarded um
so i think that this this amendment i i
think is a corrects what i see as the
as the problems in the existing law
while not in any way gutting the law so
i intend to support this amendment
uh thank you are there any other
comments
i'll rub some moonie
thank you madam chair
i can appreciate uh the thought here
however
on the amendment and i'm looking at line
i see
it was added their fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life comma or
in the discussions i have just been
privy to
i'm only hearing that that's in there
because ols decided to
to me that's unacceptable
i would ask that we have another
amendment where that language in line 10
is not
included and if we have to recess then
madam chair i would ask that that be
done
thank you
may i address that
oh yes you may okay so
in the existing
statute
the the portion at the end of line 10
already exists it already says a medical
emergency as specified defined okay
so so
in this
write-up there are
that that remains but we're also
inserting a fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life
exception as well
the
repeating of it because oos suggested it
is the one down on page
where that same language is repeated on
23 and 24.
so i
i i think if one
is okay
with adding
a fetal abnormalities incompatible with
life exception that this is properly
thank you
representative walner
would it be possible for us to have a uh
a caucus
yes
is uh 10 minutes enough
i think 10 minutes okay so we'll recess
for 10 minutes
uh
yeah the republicans will meet in
division one
and the democrats will meet in division
two
okay
we're gonna call this let me
see okay
i have no idea what
what's proper to say
but
we are waiting on an amendment
to hb 1609
and so
i would like to proceed
to the other
bills
that hhs has and i'm a little annoyed
because representative edwards promised
not yet
hb 1622 relative to mental health parity
is an otp
do i have a motion
so moved do i have a second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes ma'am this is uh the third of the
three where um
the
policy committee made an amendment
and after that
there was no um fiscal note any longer
no fiscal impact
so
like the other two i recommend we otp
this and
subsequently put it on consent
thank you
seeing none will the clerk call the rule
thank you madam chair
representative weiler yes representative
theroge yes represent petri votes yes
representative emrick yes
representative
representative edwards yes
representative berner yes
representative lynn yes
representative mooney yes
representative
yes
representative waller
representative norgren yes
representative buco yes representative
leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers yes
president walsh yes
erosion of heath yes
representative murray yes representative
hamburger
yes
let vote madam yeah yeah something like
that
madam chair the vote is on hb 1622 fn
21-0
thank you
hb
1622 otp passes 21 to 0.
without objection i'd like to put this
on the consent calendar
okay thank you
move now to hb
1642 relative to lead testing in
children
is recommended itl
could i have a motion
madam chair i
would like to move that we
[Music]
itl
1642. thank you do i have a second
second
okay representative erf
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes ma'am um
attempts to treat
lead
poisoning testing
in the same way in which
the immunization program is is is
managed and the offensive part of that
is that it places authority in the
schools
for example in the in the day care
centers but i'm more concerned about the
schools actually it it it requires them
to become an enforcement arm
of the state
to
ensure that parents are complying with
the lead poison testing
now we had testimony
that suggested that after two years of
pandemic and lockdowns
not surprisingly compliance with the
lead
poison testing
was down around the 67 percent margin
and we we want to get that up higher as
a
as a critical element of the public
health system
but um but rather than
essentially empowering the schools to
enforce
the law
um
we
the majority thought it would be better
to have
the department put together a parental
public education program
because
most people comply once they realize how
important the lead poison testing is
and it's just an inappropriate role
to have the schools
acting as a police
enforcement arm of the state
their job is to educate children and
work in partnership
with
the parents
and that
partnership relationship
is harmed
when the school becomes an authority
over the parents it
puts the arrows completely in the wrong
direction of who's accountable to who
so um
so for that
i i the majority on the committee
recommends uh itl now it's it's possible
that the bill can be improved a little
you know it but but i'd rather just itl
it and uh and be clear about uh about it
thank you
are there any further comments
thank you madam chair
so i had some concerns about this
bill in
the area of both the schools and the
child care centers and
children might be denied entry to child
care or might be
actually
asked to leave after the six months if
they did not have the
have the
test on the form the information on the
form i think it's important i think that
having the information on the form is
important
i think both the schools and child care
can certainly get involved in
encouraging parents
but i was concerned about the
about the
whole area of
denying
denying entrance
and um i did i will be voting i will be
voting against the itl because i think
there might have been a better way for
us to
are you suggesting that perhaps
you don't like the bill as it stands is
that correct
i did have an amendment drafted um
for the division
which would have made it clear that um a
child could not be denied entry
um
into a child care facility or removed
because they didn't have this on the on
the form
so i did have that but that um
but the itl overrode that amendment okay
are there any other
comments
okay
seeing none
um
thank you madam chair
we're voting on hb 1642
fn to itl
representative wilder yes
represent a petri vote yes
representative emerick yes
version of earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes representative turcotte yes roger
walner
no
where's an organ
representative bucco
no
representative leashman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers no
representative walsh no
resident heath no
representative murray no
representative umberger yes
madam share the vote on hb 1642 fn
it2itl is 11 yes
man i'm sure
i i'm wanting to write the committee
report on that and and one of the points
i meant to make was that there's an
article 28 a issue in here as well
because we would be asking the schools
for example to become enforcers and
we're not going to pay them so that is
the definition of an unfunded mandate
giving them more work and no more money
okay
hb 1642
uh passes
11 to 10.
ita
minority report well we'll get to those
in a minute okay
i need to give kevin a few more minutes
obviously
um
hb 1647
relative to calculation of child support
uh
is recommended
ought to ask
could i have a motion please
um madam chair um i i have an amendment
to this so i'll be uh wanting to move
second
all right so
you are moving
let's do the motion of otp first okay
so you're going to make that motion
i'm i'm moved that we accept
1647 otp okay and who was going to
second that
weiler acquirer okay yeah wyler now we
can go to the amendment
which is
could i have a motion please
i i move that we accept the amendment
number you just said and i'm struggling
okay would you like to speak to your
motion
uh yes yes ma'am um
the underlying bill has two major
components to it
and uh it passed out of division three
four to three
with the opposition
uh taking
a a incredibly viable perspective
that the department was just absolutely
unable to give us any financial data
upon which that we could make an
informed judgment
now
as it turns out in my view
in these two components there's a
component
that
protects
a parent's
reserve levels
so that
they have the ability to sustain
themselves and and it's been at 115
of the federal poverty guideline for
quite a while
so the the part of the bill
increased that self-support reserve to
150 150 35 percentage points
with this amendment
if if if we were to accept that in the
bill
that's the part that creates the fiscal
uncertainty
we what what that
that'll do is it will certainly protect
parents in the lower income levels from
having to pay child support but that
means that the state needs to step in
and and pay
and play a bigger role in
child support payments
so
so we don't know how much that is
and the department couldn't help us and
the department said
hey we've got this quadrennial review
coming and we'll have a report in
december we might have some information
for you in december
so this amendment says
let's freeze
the self-support reserve level at 115
percent
until the department can give us the
financial data for the finance committee
to make an informed decision
it allows the second component of this
to go forward and i don't want to speak
too much about that because that's in
are there any other comments
represent walner
thank you
so what concerned me about the bill and
though representative edwards
did come in with this amendment to try
to um
help make us feel i think more
comfortable with with the with the bill
what what bothered me was that we really
the department was not able to give us
any
kind of information about what would
happen
in situations where
people
would find themselves in need of for
instance we might increase our tanf
rolls
we might increase
the number the amount of money that was
spent for child care
the state could be looking at larger
food stamp
eligibility people being eligible for
food stamps so
we didn't really have any of that
financial information
and though i think he made a good
make sure that
there wouldn't be any
big changes i
wasn't sure that there weren't other
parts of the bill that would end up
causing us
to have a financial
impact and um
we are the finance committee and i
thought we should
be getting that kind of information the
department
did tell us that they are doing a report
that is going to be done this during the
fall and
by december
where they will be able to give us that
kind of information and i thought it was
worth
waiting to hear that
and i would
i would have gone for interim study on
this i think it is exactly the kind of
bill the finance committee should be
looking at more closely
and interim study would give us the
are there any other comments represent
waltz
thank you manager
so
i've been here a long time i started in
2004 on the children and family law
committee and in 2004 is when the state
passed the law that basically changed
the way we approach
shared parenting it was revolutionary at
the time we were some of the first in
the country if not the first in the
world to do it
and i served four terms on children and
family one of which i was chair and this
concept has come up over and over again
of trying to tie
support to uh time to custody time we
don't use the word custody but to
parental parental tie time with the
parent
and
um
there were always
really complicated reasons not to do it
and when this came forward this time i
was very surprised that it actually
passed the committee because
over and over when we looked at it it
created some very complicated and very
expensive results excuse me i'd ask you
to talk to the amendment
which is um
talking about the hundred and fifteen
percent when we move to the otpa if
that's what happens then your comments
are appropriate thank you so
getting to the fact that it had
expensive and unintended results the
amendment is one of those things that
that would do that so there the
member who sponsored the amendment said
and i wrote this down
that 115 of the federal poverty
guideline would be enough to sustain the
family and
well
sustain to sustain self and then
i presume that also means 115 of the
federal guidelines would vary depending
on how many children there are
so
that would be to sustain the self and
those children when they're with that
okay well i did write down sustained
self those were the words that you said
because i i wanted to be accurate in
what i was saying representative
and so
i'm concerned that if we pass this
we are and particularly at the 115
percent we are potentially impoverishing
one parent and the way the guidelines
would work is if you could have
really disproportionate incomes with one
parent versus another
and if they've got shared
cust shared parenting time where they're
with them equally you could have an
amount so small that one parent cannot
realistically provide an adequate home
for the children when you're looking at
these kinds of numbers it is the reason
that for the last 20 some years we have
gone against this and this 115 reserve
is consistent with the problems that
have
evolved over the last 20 years
so that's why i'm one of the reasons i'm
opposing both the amendment and the bill
is i think it's going to particularly at
this number of only 115 as opposed to
150 percent that the policy committee
did
it will result in one parent being
impoverished
uh
i have a question
what is current law in this regard
the current law is 115
okay so we're not
we're going
all we're doing is saying current law
well except that we would freeze it at
the current law levels until we had the
information from the department to make
a judgment about
whether or not it should be raised and
by how much okay thank you but excuse me
may i address that
i believe current law does not tie
support to parenting time the current
law ties support to income of each
parent not the parenting time and by
tying it to parenting time is what's
going to result in this impossible of a
parent and the 115 percent when that's
where what's going to be considered
you're going to have some parent where
you're going to have really not enough
money to sustain a household
okay thank you
um
is there anything
in this bill
that deals with co-parenting
uh there is but that's in the main bill
and i was trying to stick to the
amendment good okay so we'll get to that
later all right are there any more
uh because my quote was uh i think
misquoted i may i come back and and
restate what i believe i said and
certainly what i i think i meant
what i would i yes you may thank thank
you so much
um the concept of a self-support reserve
this isn't my concept it's the concept
that's in law today
is that that is the level that an
individual would need to have in order
to support themselves
whether or not
they can support themselves or not at
that level
is is not what i'm saying right now i'm
just saying that that hundred and
fifteen percent
is the
current laws attempt to shield money for
the individual so that they can sustain
themselves
thank you
okay are there any further comments
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
on amendment two zero two two
one one seven one
thank you madam chair
uh
representative weiler yes representative
burroughs yes president of petrie votes
yes representative emerick yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin yes
representative edwards
yes representative mirner yes
representative lin yes
rosanna mooney yes rosanna charcot yes
representative walner
no
thank you
version of norgan no
represent bucco no
representative leishman no
representative
hatch represent rogers no
problems on walls no
roseanne of heath no
representative murray no
version of umberger
yes
madam chair the vote on 1647 amendment
2022 1171 h is 12 to 9
okay amendment
2022-1179
uh passes at 21 or 20.
12 in favor 9 opposed
um
could i please have an otpa
madam chair i would like to move uh
otpa
using amendment
1171 to house bill
1647. second
was that representative earth
okay thank you
are there further comments on
[Music]
yes yes ma'am i can comment on it please
may i yes okay so um as i mentioned as
we were discussing the amendment there
are two big components to this bill
and we we just dealt with the one that
was publicly stated to be the concern
that we couldn't get our arms around the
fiscal numbers so we deferred that
what's the big the other big component
the other big component
is essential because of a 2018 court
ruling
that basically said that
regardless or independent of
the joint custody agreement
the person with more money would pay
entirely the entire joint custody
payment and pay it to
the lesser income individual
this
has caused the courts a great deal of
concern
because
um
they they have uh acted a little
independently and arbitrary uh between
the different judges and they've asked
for the legislature to step forward with
a formula
to weight
how much should go
to
into joint custody and what the
percentage of sharing is
so like if you know
representative earth and i were having
this
argument and he had the kid 40 percent
of the time and i had the kids 60
then there would be a shift in resources
to compensate me for that 20 percentage
points that's what the formula does is
to figure out how much should be
balanced in order to keep both parents
as whole as they can so so the formula
is important because
family court is hell on earth
and
this fighting over money
and who pays how much
it has been a mess now for three or four
years and this formula will allow the
courts to
uh routinely
adjudicate the amount of money that
should go from one parent to another in
a joint parenting environment and for
that reason
i think it's time sensitive and critical
that we pass
the component that's based on the
formula so i i recommend otpa
are there further comments representing
walls
so in the 18 years i've been involved in
this this is at least the fourth change
to the
formula for determining child support uh
it seems that every couple of years the
legislature tries to tinker with it and
no matter where they ticker with it
there's always somebody that's unhappy
and there was obviously somebody that
was unhappy this time that brought
forward this particular
version of it
but i maintain that this particular
version of it is going to impoverish at
least one parent when you've got some
real disparity there in income
or even when you don't and i am not
going to be able to support this given
the effect on impoverishing a parent but
i just wanted to to
acknowledge that the courts have had
guidance ever since we went to shared
parenting back in 2004
there has been consistent guidance we'd
keep amending it but there has always
been guidance there there has always
been some sort of formula some way to do
it and the courts have implemented it
they've
amended it as we have amended the law
but this is not new guidance this is
just the latest change in the guidance
as to what's always been there
thank you are there further comments
so i believe
there's a couple issues there i i do
believe this lawsuit that
representative ed was referred to
did change
the state of things by removing
the discretion of judges
to
share the
cost between households so that's one
point
the and
another point is as far as the way this
bill
um what it does first of all it doesn't
just take into consideration the
household let's call it the less
the house go with less income
rather it looks at the fact in a
co-parenting state so traditionally
if if it was not which is what it was
many years ago it wasn't really
co-parenting the children
tended to stay with one
party
this looks at it as two separate
households so first of all the
calculation is
greater
than it would have been previously the
the total cost if you will because now
you're not talking about one household
but two household because the children's
going back and forth um so so that's
that's part of it
and that
i think addresses the lower income
situation that was being described
the real concern came
from situations where the incomes were
more closely aligned
so for instance take the case where one
party and it could be either party we
actually had representatives of both
i don't know what the right word to use
is anymore
we had people with different genders
there
talking about this
and you could essentially have one one
party have a
a an income and the other one have an
income of that same number plus one
dollar
and in that situation
a calculation would be made as to what
the total
shared cost would be
between the two households
but
all of the income all of the excuse me
all of the child care would go to the
parent the parent
making
one dollar less
so essentially the other parent has no
control over
what's happening with the child's
clothing filter and so on and so forth
even though the parents themselves are
very closely aligned in terms of
their income
so that's the goal that that's been
trying to be addressed in terms of your
share you're sharing the parenting you
have two households they might be
roughly equally sharing the parenting or
maybe it's 40 60 or whatever it doesn't
really matter
but the point is that the parent the
parent with the greater income even
though it's only slightly greater should
have
some
uh
money if you will to
support the child when that child is
with or children uh with that parent
representative walner
thank you
sort of a repeat of what i said before
but i we are the finance committee and i
don't think any of us can walk out of
here today
feeling really clear about what the cost
of this piece of legislation is
it's
going it will have an impact on artanis
and
food stamp
rolls our housing housing subsidies and
i think that um it would have been
better for us to have found out what
those what that impact was before we
move forward the policy and the
department
testified in front of us that they are
working on that now and we'll have it
thank you
any other comments
representative earth i'd like to speak
to that point as well i left that out
so the department actually did not yes
they are doing a quite quadrennial
review of
child care support
they did not state they were going to be
able to address this particular concern
the concern here is it has to do with
how many people are low income i.e under
the care of the state if you will
and how many people that would grow by
which we eliminated with the amendment
that we just passed because we're not
changing the 150 percent threshold
whereas if we did change that that would
grow that as well so there's a lot of
variability here that
cannot be readily determined under any
circumstances until
the the process until it actually
implemented
and
uh this
this had this the situation has been
studied heavily for the past i believe
it's four years i think it was in 2018
if i'm not mistaken before i was here
uh bill passed
half a million dollars was allocated to
do a thing called the casey study
which study was completed a year or so
later
and there have been a few studies in
between of less
cost
so there's no question that this process
has been studied and at this point it
seems what we need to do is implement it
representative weiler
much has been made of the fact that 115
percent hasn't been increased in 30
years
but
that's 115 of federal poverty level
that increases annually or even more so
so it's not like the same number has
been fixed for 30 years and somebody
tried to give us that impression thank
you
okay thank you very much are there any
other comments
seeing none
uh the motion on the floor is
otpa
for hb 1647.
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh
representative wilder yes
president
yes representative petrie vote yes
representative emmerich yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner yes
representative uh lynn yes
representative mooney yes
president turcotte yes rosanna walner
no
representative norgren no
representative bucco no
representative leishman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers no representative
walsh no representative heath no
representative murray no
representative umberger yes
i don't share the vote on h.b 1647 out
of passes amended as 12 to 9 any
affirmative
hb
1647 otpa
the vote was 12 in favor 9 opposed
it is approved
is one one three four
could i have a motion
um
madam chair i i i move otp and then
would like to subsequently make it otpa
no the it shows here that there was an
i
i the amendment
that i'm prepared to talk to i think is
new is
mr ripple here
this this amendment did not come over
from the policy committee if i may go
yeah somebody should you may recall
president edwards i believe the
part one part roman numeral part i i
believe you did have you did put forth
that amendment
and then you added the
other part or either that or vice versa
so i believe there's actually you and i
i think have actually seen several
amendments on this
it's my understanding 1134 is the most
recent and and got voted out of our
committee but not in front of the full
committee
right and that's the amendment where i'm
asking for a motion on is 11 34.
okay i'll i'll move 1134. i just thought
we needed to have an underlying otp no
because it's already on here as
amendment as amended all right so do i
have a second second thank you reps and
mooney
would you like to speak to your
amendment yes yes ma'am um
so
uh
hb 1662
uh establishes some privacy uh
guidelines for the department of health
and human services
and it requires for example
that they conduct a risk mitigation
[Music]
analysis
of their i.t systems
and
in order to do a privacy risk assessment
you need people with some special skills
and knowledge these are people that need
to be
fluent in what the privacy rules and
principles are and they should be pretty
fluent on i.t security issues so in
previous versions of this bill
we weren't certain what the grade level
for those skills are
but they turn out to be
labor grade 30
step five based on the analysis the
department did with whoever does the hr
for the state
um and so so they need two people
so the main reason finance dealt with
this is to get the money right and and
this amendment gets the the money right
the um the other thing that we did
which
delved just a tiny bit into the policy
side
was there was some ambiguity in the main
bill that
one of these privacy risk plans needs to
be done for each it system
the way it read somebody could
misinterpret it to mean one risk
medication strategy for all the it
systems so so we
we clarified that in there because it
that directly affects workload which can
affect manpower needs so
so it does those two things it corrects
the labor grade and the money that goes
with it and then it clarifies that uh
one of these risk mitigation plans is
needed for each it system that
processes personal data
thank you i would ask you to accept it
thank you are there any other comments
see yes
representative
thank you madam chairman my question is
there's a
uh a shortage of there's a large number
of vacancies throughout the state
did the department come forth and say
that they had identified people for this
position or were just appropriating
funds for
an empty slot
okay that's a good question just a
moment please
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair uh that that's
a good question and i i tried to address
that earlier when i said these are
unique skills finding people that are
fluent in privacy rules and principles
who are also
really very aware of i.t security the
department doesn't have those nor does
the doit who
worked with us extensively he likes this
bill so much he wants a bill like this
to do the department of i.t in the
coming year so
so this these are these are new skills
and therefore new job descriptions and
therefore new positions
um and you're right there's a huge
vacancy rate so they could maybe cover
it with their um i want to call it float
because that's the old term but
the laps we call it elapse but
okay are there any further questions or
comments
seeing none
are you ready i am ready okay well the
clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh for voting on
hb 1662
ought to pass on amendment 1134 h
representative weiler yes
presidential burris yes president petrie
votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative erf yes representative
griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner yes
uh representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
president sure caught yes
representative walner
yes
or is it an organ
roger nabucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers no
representative walsh
yes
version of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
i don't chair the vote on h.b 1662
amended amendment 22 20 22 8 11 34 11 34
each we'll get it right
20 to one
thank you affirmative all right uh the
amendment 20 22
passes 20 to 1.
uh could i have a motion for otp a
please on
1662.
um madam chair i'd like to move uh 1662
to otpa
thank you do i have a second
second
second by uh representative weiler
are there any further comments that
anyone would like to make on this bill
see none
just a short one this this this passed
the house by a very nice strong vote
this uh in the aftermath of passing the
right to privacy in 2018
this actually is legislation to start uh
moving the department uh into
a
privacy assurance role
and and i just think this is really good
bill the doit
wants to emulate it in the future
because they think it's a good deal
thank you very much
anyone else
saying no none would the clerk please
call the roll
thank you madam chair uh
this is on hb 1662 fn
the motion is ought to pass as amended
representative weiler yes representative
thorberg yes
representative petry votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative erf yes arizona griffin
yes
representative edwards yes
representative lin yes representative
mooney yes representative yes rosanna
walner yes
representative norburn
representative bucco yes
arizona leashman
yes president hatch yes
representative rogers yes
arizona walls yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair the vote on hb 1662 is ought
to pass
autopass has amended the vote is 21-0
thank you the hp
otpa is approved 21 to 0.
okay
i see that
mr ripple has returned
which is great and uh so if you'll pass
us out and while he's doing that um
uh
represent walnut have you
decided
which um
bills are going to have uh
um i need to check with um division one
folks maybe bill could speak to that we
have three and um janna already has two
of them
we have three and jenna already has two
of them and another one's coming okay
could you tell me what
i'd sign um
you have a list there
well it should be 14 17
yeah
uh 15. do you have that right here
mine's period the three
yeah 1552 1552 the majority
oh minority
15 35 14
17.
and those are one other one that's just
two okay thank you
so and who wrote them
that's okay that's okay i don't need
that right now
okay on uh
are there going to be any minority
reports
okay thank you
division three
minority reports uh 1647
and i will write that
and of course waiting to see what
happens with 1609 okay
so
the other ones
will not have a minority report
no
all right
okay
um
i'll go back to where we left off on
hp 1609
we have a new amendment
could i have a motion to
accept
amendment
to
zero nine h madam chair i i'm i move
that uh the committee accept uh
2022-1209
as an amendment to 1609. do i have okay
did you want to speak to your amendment
uh please um
so i think maybe it was representative
mooney who who caught it first in the
committee that
the
statement
that excuses or
allows for an abortion after 24 weeks in
the case of fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life
that
that that
we had used that phrase twice once in
paragraph 1 starting on line 10 and then
a second time which is now line 23
and that
to clarify the law
after a sidebar
we decided that the best thing to do is
was to delete that reference from line
10 and so now it's gone
because that would have conflicted with
the whole
requirement of the ultrasound
um and then keep it in line 23.
the rest of the amendment just clarifies
the existing statute as already in law
that that that this paragraph shall be
construed to require the performance of
an ultrasound
only if the provider either knows that
the fetus has just stationed a just
additional age of at least 24 weeks or
is conscious of a substantial risk that
the fetal has a just additional age of
at least 24 weeks
so
so this means
doctors
won't get penalized and i won't use the
mens rear quote because i'm not exactly
sure what that means
okay uh are there any other comments
i continue to be concerned that we have
um
put our finger on
policy
and that we have not that we are
changing the bill substantially from how
it came to us from health and human
services
the amendment before you
has nothing to do with finances
and it is strictly a policy it's
strictly policy
and for that reason i i will vote no to
this amendment
thank you any other comments
represent turkup thank you madam chair
um although i
am not a big proponent of this amendment
i will support it um only because it's
not quite as obnoxious as 1609 was by
itself which should have been itl
i will support this as a a way of moving
uh 1609 forward however thank you thank
you any any other comments represent
edwards uh if if i could i i would say
that when we um
provide the mother the option of having
an abortion in the case of fetal
abnormalities incompatible with life
uh that
empowers her and her physician to
exercise an option that isn't in current
law and would therefore also
back them away
from a red line to where prosecution may
have come into play so if we're looking
for a financial tie it could be
less
burdensome on the judiciary by
explicitly granting this exception in
thank you are there any further comments
okay seeing none we will now vote on
amendment to 160 hb 1609 of
2022-1209
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair
uh representative wilder yes
representative burris yes
representative petry votes yes
representative emrick
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative mirner yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney
yes representative
yes representative walter
no
representative norgren no
arizona buco no representative leishman
no
representative hatch no
representative rogers no represent walsh
no
representative heath no
representative murray no
representative burger yes
madam chair the vote on xb 1609 ought to
pass amendment
2022 1209 h
is 12 yes and nine no
okay
2 1609
2 2
1 2 0 9 h
passes
with a vote of 12 in favor and 9 opposed
so
we had an otp
motion on the floor
however we now
have an amendment
to that otp
so
otpa
do i have anyone that will make that
motion
you need to grow
second
are there
any
any questions
comments
thoughts
all right see
what happened here
i don't know oh i'm on the second sheet
and they don't have otpa on the second
shoe so that's okay
we're good okay
are you ready to
may calm
make a just a quick comment uh yes you
may the um just for clarification
uh in in the amendment uh it was
suggested that that's a change of policy
on on lines 19 through 22 clarifying
when an ultrasound is required that that
is not a change of policy it's a
clarification of what's already in the
statute we wanted to make it easier so
fewer people would misinterpret the
any any other comments
oops thank you madam chair
representative wilder yes
president suburg yes
president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative irv yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative warren burner
yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney yes representative yes
represent organ yes
no yeah
yes
thank you
representative bucco yes
arizona leashman yes
representative hatch
yes
president rogers
no
yes
representative heath yes
arizona murray yes
and representative
yes
matter chair the vote on hb 1609
as uh
in the affirmative
okay
hb
1609 as amended
passes uh
20 in favor and
okay
um
i thank you all for tolerating me all
day i'm sorry i didn't expect this
afternoon to uh to go quite this long
but uh before you leave all blurbs must
okay
yes
pardon
yes okay uh that's because i trust you
mary
all right
so you had best high tail at home
because janet needs these this afternoon
okay
so i uh
i thank you all and um
i don't think we have anything going on
until
a session
i mean we'll have obviously we'll have
some other things but
that's um that's where we are so have a
good break and enjoy life tomorrow it's
supposed to rain
oh
okay tracy so so the other thing i need
to do or you need to do or somebody
should
right
okay
uh i will need to know who the minority
speakers are oh
you